Still out,
figure it out later.
Two,
one.
Oh,
and with live,
ladies and gentlemen,
with the Creator,
are you the creator of this library?
Is Brian Brian?
Yeah.
Not Thinking yet.
He has a god.
I don't go that far.
Right?
Brain,
the right brain.
Cheers sir.
Thank you sir.
The clink,
the famous Yeti Jingle.
A rambler.
Ooh,
what a great invention.
How'd you guys will?
You guys were just getting hammered and
throwing anything in there.
Same way for folks who haven't been
properly introduced.
My friend Ben.
Oh,
is here and he's the one.
He was in the podcast from paradise when
we're in Lanai.
Kind of my all time favorites.
I mean the island or the podcast thing,
but it was all awesome.
The whole damn thing,
but people are drinking those cat ladies
now,
which is.
It's not to bad.
That's terrible idea to dudley making
that.
I was like,
what the fuck are you doing?
He Poured Tequila and red bull into a
glass of red wine and we're looking at
him like,
what is.
And people have.
Hashtags are wrong,
man.
When people are hashtagging,
of course I'd do it sometimes just to
poke fun at everybody,
but I've had probably a dozen people
like,
man,
I tried the cat lady last night just
drinking it,
just to say they drank it in,
which is just don't do it.
People don't do it,
but right brain is actually pretty good.
I can get that.
We were,
there were some meat,
some trigger,
some bose involved and stuff just got
put together.
And I've had these before.
They actually tastes good.
But um,
there's like no benefit that you get
from our list.
It's like all the science,
we put it into Alpha brain,
all the non science from whiskey out the
window phones.
Totally.
Well,
I mean it's a,
he's made zero leaps forward but we're
good where we are currently.
Maybe it my balance us out though.
It keeps from getting too stupid,
which that's a,
that's a good achievement.
Do big issue with whiskey.
What does this whiskey we got here?
This is,
I don't know if Jamie just kinda like
throw it out there.
Gave us at the comedy store.
It's called Angel's envy.
Oh,
that sounds like a think like angels are
really envious of whiskey though.
I mean,
you're hanging out with God.
You can fly.
We want to buy it in a store with angel
ended enough money.
Maybe that sounded balances.
It's got wings on the back.
Maybe it's they're trying to market with
red bull.
I don't know.
Those are always the wings on the back
of a stripper that cries a lot and there
were an angel and envy are both names,
strippers that I've that I've never,
never seen that.
It's a really good point.
Yeah.
The wings on the back is always a weird
move.
Right?
But if you're listening,
if you're drinking whiskey with,
with an Alpha brand,
you can do whatever you want.
You can put whatever you want,
whatever kind of whiskey you want in
there.
You're very open minded.
Yeah.
The Alpha brain cancels that out.
It could be,
give me the worst whiskey in the world
and the Alpha brain makes it better.
Have you taken this anywhere?
This a right brain have not really
counting on your listeners and deadlies
fans to do that.
I want it to be organic.
It can spread brown the next time you go
to some exotic location and they have a
right,
like if you're in Nepal.
Oh,
I'm going to a northwest.
Territory's will here.
Or your boys on your hat there.
The eastmans oh you really like a week.
Oh Wow.
I will.
You do it up there.
Caribou and dall sheep.
Oh Wow.
So we're doing a film about their Yeti
film.
Yeti presents to them about their family
history and the northwest territories.
Like technically what part of Alaska is
that?
So that's.
It's east of Alaska,
right?
East of British Columbia.
It's up towards the Arctic circle.
So we'll fly into norman wells and go
north from there,
up into the Mckenzie mountains,
which are about as far north as you can
get before hit.
The Arctic circle will be sniffing the
arctic circle and most days.
But it's still still Alaska,
right?
No,
no,
no.
Its own territory.
Real.
Yep.
Oh Wow.
Same as Yukon.
I mean,
you know,
you think Yukon Moose or whatever.
They're all their own territories.
That's.
Oh,
so he's Yukon is not Alaska.
We'd have to look that up.
I don't want to be right.
I'd have to look at a globe and I'm
looking.
I'm not questioning like I know.
I mean I don't know either,
but northwest territories is its own
territory.
It's not alive.
So who owns that?
Canada,
I guess.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh,
so it's like past Alaska becomes Canada
again.
This is getting real deep.
I should've known Kevin on this package
here,
like tell me the history of northwest
territories.
So here it is right now on a map.
So you kind of.
Territory is the Yukon is slightly east
or east rather east and then the
northwest territories course is further
east above Alberta.
So you're getting up there into,
into the Arctic and it is connected to
Canada.
Yeah.
But it's also connected to Alaska.
It's no,
it's to Yukon Party Canada.
It's one of the provinces had it.
Right.
I'm getting confused myself.
Yeah.
I thought that the British Columbia
section.
So I saw a British Columbia.
I thought that was part of Alaska.
You could read the wikipedia.
It's always really.
It's really different.
Dramatic,
wild mountainous and sparsely populated.
It's crazy that it's north of northern
Alberta,
like people like,
you know what,
it's just not fucking cold enough here
in the winter.
We've got to keep going.
Well they have lakes.
They've got.
I mean they have lakes for like a month.
I don't know.
I think when we're up there,
we were talking about last week.
I think when we're up there there'll be
no,
it'll be daylight 24 hours a day.
Oh Wow.
I believe now when you do that,
do you bring like one of those eyeball
cover things?
Uh,
yeah.
We'll have to.
Yeah,
the mask,
I have all covered things.
Whatever you have to.
You have to.
Unless you really,
unless you can get into 10 just Kinda
zonked out.
But it's,
it's 12,
I think it's 12 or 13 days up there.
So by the time you get to day five or
six years,
I mean you're living out of your
backpack.
You're carrying probably 50,
60,
70 pounds in your pack and climbing
every day.
So I mean it's probably the time you get
laid down.
I don't think it matters.
Well,
what's going on now when you do
something like that?
Um,
how much gear you guys bring you living
entirely out of your backpack.
So when the float plane is what in the,
in the plane takes you to base camp,
which I think in this case is there's
not a float plane.
Well,
so we'll be,
it'll be a wheel plane.
We'll we can take 50 pounds and then
sounds each 50 pounds plus your body
weight,
plus you evaluate and then six days in
they will either come in a helicopter
and pick us up and move us if we're not
having any luck or they'll just drop us
more gear.
So you can.
So the plan would be take 50 pounds of
essential gear and then have other gear
as backup back at base camp.
Oh Wow.
So you fly into base camp.
It's like for me it will be like Austin
to Denver,
Denver to Edmonton,
Edmonton to Norman Wells,
hoppa charter to base camp.
And then from there fly out into the
hunting areas.
How many days travel is that?
It was like two days and change two days
solid of just flying.
Just flying was your overnighting
because they.
I mean they run like one added Norman
Wells.
They run like one flight a day or
something.
One or two flights a day.
You have to be really dedicated to this
kind of experience to travel.
Just travel for two days.
I once you do it,
man,
that's like the only way to go though.
Really?
It's once you.
It's not the only way to go.
That's Douchey to say,
but it's like the best.
Most when you get back you're like,
man,
that sucked,
but I wouldn't want to change it.
You something happens to people when
they do those like exotic location,
like when they go sheep hunting and they
risked their lives.
Like I've seen some video of guys like,
well I saw some video of you guys when
you were in New Zealand.
Yeah.
When you were risking your lives with
every step.
Yeah.
It's the whole time too.
It's not just like,
oh,
we got up to this one area where the
sheep live.
You're just where we were in,
in,
in New Zealand with green tree.
We when you get up into,
so there's like beachwood far,
so you're looking at like a 3000,
30 540,000
foot mountain,
right?
You're,
we stayed in a little hut in the river
valley and so when you're down there,
you're looking up,
you're like,
oh,
that's where the tar live.
Huh?
Oh,
43,000
feet from where we are right now.
For people that don't know is a crazy
looking animal Himalayan.
Yeah.
It looks like a lord of the rings or
something.
It really does.
Yeah.
It looks like a wooly mammoth,
but just a miniature version.
Yeah,
really crazy.
We'll leave furry,
shaggy a goat essentially like a goat
slash sheet.
But I mean the funny part about all that
is,
is when you heard those right there,
look at the image they look like where
we,
where you would look across these
little,
these Alpine valleys and you'd see him
look like a black bear looks like a
giant black bear.
And he just thinking,
where am I and what is that thing?
God.
So I'm not like you have some really
cool adventure or on this podcast.
That's not me.
When I see that thing,
I think what the fuck am?
Where am I like it?
It's wild looking.
Yeah.
And they live up in the Alpine.
So there you've got the beech wood
forest,
which is probably,
if I would just say hiking straight up
for about an hour and a half or two
hours.
And is that an innovation species for
New Zealand?
They're feral,
not feral.
That's.
I don't know.
They're non native.
So all the mammals on the island,
they're non native.
All of them were all were introduced by.
And I wish I had really looked up
someone specific,
but they are all introduced by other
countries.
Europe sent animals over there,
Teddy Roosevelt sent some animals over
there like,
hey,
I hear you're going to want these.
And so the problem over there to get on
a whole different subject is that the
people on that island,
the residence of,
of New Zealand don't value those animals
as part of the landscape.
They're just there.
I mean,
Farrell would be a good term sheet of
the way they view them to the value they
have on them.
We have like moose mule deer.
That's,
that's part of our ethos as a country.
Right.
And our ecosystems and our ecosystem,
they've been here before.
We were some level and so over there
they just,
they'll jump in the helicopter and mowed
down like 40 red stag on a weekend
because they want to control the
population one because there's no winter
kill and their predation,
all that stuff.
But they also just don't see a big red
stag the way we see a big elk.
They just don't,
they don't have the value for it down
there.
Well,
it's also the weird thing about having
no predators is how do you handle that?
Do you bring in predators?
Like if they don't,
they risk disease and there's all sorts
of weird things that can happen like,
like they have on Lanai.
Yes.
Yeah.
And so that's it.
Right.
And we've had,
we've done that in this country with
bringing down a northwest.
What's the timber wolf that we brought
him down and put them in the states and
that's while that may seem like a good
solution and we,
when we were in British Columbia Hunt
Moose together,
we saw some calf skeletons.
Yeah.
We showed that picture on the podcast.
It was kind of fucked up.
That thing has just been decimated.
Those wolves and I saw in Montana one
time I saw them running circles.
They run in like concentric circles.
I just run like a bullseye pattern when
they're hunting.
I feel like the packs and I just
watched.
We were.
I killed my elk on the first day of this
hunt and I was watching and you would
show there be a different wolf kill like
every other day in this valley and it's
like the wolves were just running in
circles and I did see a couple of bulls
fighting that in that trip.
Trying to call him in.
Yeah,
some of them.
two of them.
Wow.
That was like 1200 yards away and I had
a rifle and I was thinking.
I was thinking about it,
but I mean once you see,
when you see a dead fon everyday you go
hunting and pre a new,
maybe not new to that day,
but knew that week you started to think
like how if this pack work this valley
for a full year,
what could they do?
And there's numbers to that.
Somewhere at some people have figured
out what,
how many elk?
A year upon the eldest son,
Kale,
before the wolves were reintroduced,
there was an issue with overpopulation,
so it.
So that's where I think that's probably
100 come in,
you know,
you could,
I,
I value that animal.
I'm willing to pay you for the
opportunity to help you conserve that
population.
And so that's,
that becomes very problematic for
people.
Like when you start talking about
wolves,
dogs does wilderness or another one of
those ones that black bears too.
I mean,
I think it's,
you don't eat them.
I mean even more than any tools way more
than any that was talking to.
There was a gal in my work that I was
talking to and she lives in Austin,
Texas and is very,
not a hunter,
but works at Yeti,
and so she's around hunting and we were
talking about wolves and I just said,
look,
I don't have a really hard and opinion
on bulls.
I've not spent enough time around them.
I just know that their meat processors
on four legs,
they give no shits about anything.
They don't.
They're not just eating,
they don't just eat what feels their
belly.
They eat and then they eat more and they
kill more,
and that's all they're wired to do.
Right.
I've seen that in action,
so that's all I really know.
I don't know whether that's good for an
ecosystem bad,
whatever,
and she just said,
well,
I didn't really know that it's hunting
has really bad wolves will seem to have
a good pr agent and hunting and
management have a terrible pr agent,
you know,
so I think that,
that's,
that's part of the problem,
that there's a sect of people that are
really glorifying a wolf for good
reason.
I mean,
it's awesome animal that majestic
animal,
but at the same time there is a
juxtaposition of that that needs to be
told to.
Well,
I think a big part of the issue is that
people know that they virtually wiped
them out in North America at one point
in time.
And I think people feel guilty about
that.
Yeah.
Well,
and then they should feel guilty.
They should feel ashamed about the
Mallard duck elk.
People don't know the detail.
Yeah.
But we brought those back to the point
where the numbers are higher than
they've ever been before.
But those same people don't know how
that happened though.
Right?
Those same people aren't aware of how
they just see white tails around.
They're like,
oh,
that's annoying.
People with the car.
They don't know that it turn of the
century.
They were almost all gone.
Yeah.
Because we market hunting them to hell.
Uh,
and so I think that's,
there's just,
it's just education,
man.
I just think people need to seek the
other side,
which I always try to do and you do all
the time,
just seek whatever the other side is.
And the hunting is not always the way to
go yet,
but it's inconvenient because like it's
hard,
like if,
say if you're a vegetarian or a Vegan,
you're going to get your information
from animal rights activists and it's
going to be biased in that direction.
Or if you're a hunter,
you're going to get your information
from hunting and conservation groups and
it might be biased in the other way.
And I think wolves are a good thing
because they're awesome.
You know,
I don't know.
I don't not like walls I think know
hunter's like wipe the wolves that I've
never heard that I've just started like
what's the carrying capacity for this
state but this region for wolves.
Right?
How many can there be?
And,
and I know in a lot of cases,
you know,
the biologists would say one thing like,
okay,
here's 100 bulbs in this area.
And then when it ballooned up to a
thousand,
they argued for hunters come in and help
put that population down.
There were still a pushback,
like,
wait a minute,
we said we agreed upon scientifically,
biologically,
you know,
we,
we know the problem is that it's
negotiable at all.
It should have been like once the wolves
hit 2000 starting,
then you start a hunting season,
but then the real issue is it's
incredibly hard to shoot a wolf like
this.
It's not as simple as you ought and find
a wolf and kill them.
They're really smart and they think
about Tara and New Zealand.
You can't just like if they're over
populated in there,
you can't just like,
oh,
we'll just walk up the hill and crack a
couple.
I mean that's,
that's a pretty big feat.
So they jumped in a helicopter and
that's gone down the tar that way to
really,
God damn.
So how do they determine whether or not
they should be getting them down?
It's a no,
and I don't know like the holistic
method that I use,
but I know our guide up there this year
was just talking about he would go to
the,
to the sheep stations or the ranch
owners or are some of the areas.
Some of those big mountain are own
privately and some of the areas where
they were down a little bit lower than
they would just say go out today and
kill a hundred and that's what they
would do and it was,
it was not,
it didn't seem to me to be too
scientific in the way they went about
it,
but it's a private land owner telling
you,
hey these,
this is an infestation essentially,
and my argument to them was like,
why don't you just,
these animals are here,
they're not going anywhere,
they're not going to swim over to
Australia.
Why don't you just treat them like we
treat our,
our wildlife whilst you just accept
them.
And then there was some people down
there that were agreed with me whole
heartedly.
Some people in the guide and outfitting
community just like,
why don't you just accept these animals
as part of your landscape and treat them
like that.
And I think that's,
that's a swelling opinion down there for
sure.
Well,
how do they accept.
I mean they just treat them like their
pasts.
I wouldn't say pass because they do have
some value because hunters from around
the world would go down there like we
did,
but don't have a lot of,
um,
a lot of that is on public lands or
excuse me,
private land in those high fence places.
And that's,
that's basically stag.
You can't really.
It's going to be,
it's hard to high fence for shaming tar.
They just live in places very.
He'd been down to put up if he tried,
you'd be dumb.
But stag stag is a whole different deal
down there.
Yeah.
I mean it's because they're so big,
like they,
the people want to go there and get a
big day rack of antlers to their
discredit,
like they have harvested the bad parts
of our hunting culture and marketed it
brilliantly.
They have.
Um,
and I think there's a lot of people down
there that would push back on that,
um,
on that idea.
But yeah,
explain that,
what that means by the bad parts and not
just the American hunting culture
because there's a lot of Europeans that
go there too.
I think the parts of the trophy hunting,
the hey come down here and,
and,
and work on this five inch tag.
We've got it here and they have agents
that go around and sell it for $500.
We're talking about folks is the size of
the antlers,
not the size of the actual animal itself
that people get super obsessed and they
fetish numbers like you know the score
and what a score is for people don't
know.
They take a tape measure and they go
over very specific sections of the
antlers and they calculate all the
measurements together and when they do
that they come up with some number and
there's these milestone benchmark
numbers like a 200 inch white tails,
a huge deer or a 400 inch elk is a huge
elk.
It is.
They get stags and go to 500 and more,
more and more insane.
And is it as big as an elk looking
animal body size?
Not quite close but not quite.
And and I and one of the sheep stations
we hunted with originally,
they farm.
They essentially form red deer,
red deer and stag.
Same thing are walking around in,
these are the same animal.
No down there.
Red Stag,
red years.
Basically the same thing,
but you find red deer in Europe and
they're different.
Oh genius.
Why do they call them a stack but isn't
a stagnant of male stag,
stag and,
and high and being the female h I n D,
yeah.
And so,
but you would call it a,
you would call the animals are red deer.
I've heard it called low 500 in Europe
and they call it a red deer there.
So I'm not sure those deer came from
there anyway.
So I'm sure it's the same.
So they came and they dropped them off
in the 18 hundreds just to turn the
whole place into a giant like hunting
provision.
Right.
Some level at some level.
I'd love to read the history of that.
I don't really haven't gone that far
back,
but he said that before they came there
was no mammals there.
Yeah.
Like what a weird patch of land.
It's a weird like New Zealand is,
is definitely coming from where we come
from and all the things we have and we
just find it normal that we can hunt how
many,
how many huntable species are there on
this?
Um,
you know,
on this continent going down there,
it's just such a weird.
But in the end they celebrate the
outdoor culture.
They celebrate hunting and fishing in
the way that almost in the way that we
do and they have public land much like
we do and they're publicly and his is
more revered and more well managed and
better taken care of.
I think that our public lands and it's
more usable and so they have all these
like similar properties that we have in
America,
but at some level they're just,
I think they just got poor luck.
They don't have native mammals too.
They don't have the Bald Eagle to put on
their master.
They,
they just have these,
you know,
essentially shammy tar and tar aren't,
they're not native either.
No.
None of those.
None of them native.
None of them.
They also have Canadian geese that are
not native.
Right.
Did you notice you used to have the
biggest ego in the world?
Really?
Yeah.
These,
to have an eagle called the Haast Eagle
and apparently they killed them off in
the 14 hundreds and they were so big.
There's speculation.
They used to eat people.
I'd kill them all.
Foot 14 foot wingspan I think is what we
figured out.
I'm not exaggerating if you've ever been
over there.
It's.
It really is like if it's a place where
that kind of eagle would live,
that's what it looked like.
Leash.
That's what a hostile looks like.
We're looking at an eagle that's
literally the size of a big person and
that's up the look at the size of that
fucking thing and so this can be.
That's Gandalf.
I mean look,
if it's as big as a person like that
picture,
go to that first picture again,
like,
yeah,
look how big that thing is.
I mean,
if that thing spreads its wings,
if you had been over there,
the landscape over there and some of the
Alpine areas that it looks like a place
where that would live,
that will kill you.
That thing,
if they caught you hiking,
it would just pull you off the cliff and
just drop you off.
Oh,
that's not a real hot steagall.
The actual hostile with Google images.
We're getting all kinds.
We got Gandalf riding an eagle.
We got.
But that one,
that one with the emus or whatever the
fuck
those animals are.
Is that a box that he's carried?
That one's here.
Oh yeah.
So when did it go extinct,
Jamie?
What does it say?
Look at the size of the dude standing
next to what?
The skeleton of a hostile.
And he was that dude.
That dude is awesome.
I'm looking at him.
Yeah,
he looks like a wizard.
Who's robes?
That's an ancient intellectual and it
really opened the door for 1,680.
I don't know what it says.
The real thing actually lived on earth
and of course it was known as the tiger
and the tiger skin.
That's not that long ago.
1,600.
Holy Shit.
I thought it was 14 hundreds because
there are six feet tall.
Oh wait.
Only 35 pounds and it had a wingspan of
10 feet.
Wow,
that's crazy.
[inaudible],
they're hollow bones.
I guess.
Thirty five pounds doesn't seem that
much,
man.
How do you go back to that picture?
How the fuck is that thing?
Thirty five pounds.
There's nothing.
Six feet tall.
10 foot wingspan that things only 35
pounds.
That seems wrong.
Turkeys heavy.
Like you pick up a Turkey and like 25
pound range.
Look at the size of the thing.
He's all big.
Every time I'm hanging around you.
I hear.
I hear about these evil mystical
animals.
Well,
I think giant bear concern was that the
Haast Eagle,
they might have killed it off like the
local New Zealand folks might've killed
it off back then because they were
eating people.
I do not blame them and see if that's
the truth.
That might be a lie.
Did didn't know about this hostile you
like doing,
you know I weighed 100 at a place called
hostile when you're were over there.
So maybe connection.
Maybe we were really find and maybe find
some ancient eagle skull.
They go hook ball to see if at eight
people relationship with human google
that.
See where it says relationship with
humans.
Yeah,
do do,
do,
could have been possible to do even
smaller Golden Eagles are capable of
killing.
Yeah.
They said they kill humans,
which scientists believe could have been
possible.
If the name relates to the Eagle,
given the massive size of the strength
of the bird.
Even smaller Golden Eagles are capable
of killing praise.
[inaudible] biggest Sitka deer or bear
cub?
Yeah.
That fucking thing killed a few people
for sure.
Like a baby.
You didn't think.
Yeah,
like a baby.
You don't think that a Predator like
that did not learn what it could and
could not go get that.
So the sculptures,
goofy sculpture,
the sculpture,
is that the sculpture we were looking
at?
Maybe?
Yeah,
it was approximation of it.
It says it's seven point five meters 25
feet tall.
No,
that wasn't 25 feet tall with a wingspan
of 11 point five meters.
Thirty eight feet.
Oh,
okay.
That's that.
That's the art park that we're looking
at news.
That's just a giant sculpture of animal.
Okay,
I get ya.
But uh,
there's a really cool eagle that lives
in the rainforest called the heartbeat
eagle.
That eats monkeys.
Want
to know about this stuff?
Man?
I find myself in a room in a rain forest
a couple months.
Be Looking for Harpy Eagles all over
time.
Well,
there was a dude that was trying to put
a camera in a heartbeat.
Eagle Nest,
and he got attacked by a heartbeat.
Eagle.
So it shouldn't have been doing that.
Scientists should have worked in a movie
theater or something.
It was his thing,
man.
See if you can stop looking at these.
Terrible.
The way.
Cool looking because it's kind of white.
Look,
we and we were talking about this when
we were in Lanai.
I have a problem swimming in the ocean
because I'm feeling like I look like a
seal all the time when I'm in there and
I feel like sharks will.
They're like,
look at that.
Like I just got this bolt.
His legs bitten off yesterday in
Florida.
See?
Yeah.
This is awareness man.
CHOMP chomp shrunk.
So now I'm scared of this guys,
thanks to this.
You know that the bull shark swim so far
up river that they live in fresh water
and they have been found as high as
Illinois God,
as they go up to fucking Illinois and
they're the most aggressive sharks.
I heard that.
I've heard that before.
At least to live right on the Illinois
River.
Will they also are the reason why the
movie jaws wasn't inspired by a great
white shark.
It was inspired by a series of attacks
by bull sharks and freshwater rivers in
New Jersey.
We talk about something else now.
It's freaking me out and they made the
music like,
oh,
it's terrible.
Yeah.
Johnson,
your psyche,
that stuff changed.
What would the music be for one of those
big eagles?
Same.
It would be death metal.
Yeah.
He'd be out in the field,
do death metal music.
I've seen too much over in Nepal.
They have these big things called longer
guys.
It's like if it's a Nepali Griffin,
it looks like a big old vulture.
You look at that thing up,
see what the wingspan on those,
but they'd be.
We'd be up on some mountain glass if
your sheep and there'd be like a giant
thing with the airplane,
eight,
nine foot wingspan and you could see the
creepiest part to me was you could see
their heads move back and forth,
like,
look,
they were,
they were looking for shit and they,
they take,
they take and kill a baby sheep.
I saw a video,
but after I got back and I was going to
freaking out about these things.
I mean,
it's a vulture.
Yeah,
it's like a Nepali.
They call it a longer guyer.
And when we were there,
they told us all you're gonna see
Griffin's so it,
it had a variety of names,
like everything there seems to have.
Um,
but it's,
uh,
it looks like a vulture.
It's like a giant.
I didn't know that they hunted.
That's interesting.
I thought they just say,
well,
I watched something on like a planet
Earth about them and that they showed
them in packs and they were,
they eat bone marrow.
So they would,
they would get a bone off the ground,
fly up into the air and strategically
drop it onto the ground.
So it would crack open,
fly down,
eat the,
eat the insides.
Wow.
Yeah.
I haven't figured that out at the same
thing.
You could just see their brains churn
and like a lot of times you see it an
animal in the sky burdened sky.
You sick.
It's soaring around.
But you could see the predatory brain of
this laundry guy as it flew above us,
just churn.
And as I looked around for what to get
after.
Well they say ravens are stupid.
Smart.
Like a smart as chimps.
Yeah.
So you think about this bird,
the bird's brain,
the size of what?
I don't know.
Limit,
but yeah,
it's.
It literally found out I want to get
inside that bone.
I'm going to fly up and drop it.
Some vision net insights.
Well,
somewhere along the line they figured a
long time ago how to drop things off
cliffs.
Absolutely.
They've been doing that with goats and
stuff.
There's a ton of videos of them grabbing
goats and pulling them out like eels
curricular.
Whoa.
That's the longer guy.
What is that thing?
That thing looks fucking evil,
man.
Holy Shit.
Look at that face on that thing.
I think when I was over there when we
were in in the mountains,
I just wrote like a whole page about
this longer yard.
We saw.
I don't remember it being taller.
That's amazing.
It's like one of the zoo.
Oh my God.
They were jet black.
The ones we saw.
Imagine how scary that looks,
but just being jet black.
Wow.
The coloration.
What does that.
A bone above mouth and swallowing whole.
Yep.
Oh,
primitive creature.
Just like complete emotionless eyes.
Yeah.
That's.
I,
I vividly remember looking up at some
point and seeing these things floating
in the breeze and looking around and
thinking that thing is savage.
How big do they get?
Jamie?
What a weird name.
Lumber guy or how do you spell it?
L A,
m,
m e R G E I r over there.
They described it originally our guy
described as a griffin
but at Griffin's like a mythological.
No,
that's why I was thinking I'm going to
see this mythological.
I was waiting for something to land and
talk to us.
That's like,
that's a place in New Zealand is like,
that's,
that's a perfect location.
If they ever decided to do like some
sort of a Jurassic Park taught
actuation.
Well even Lanai,
right?
Four feet tall.
Nine foot wings hair.
It is.
Wow Man.
Again.
We'll get this weight.
Fifteen pounds.
That's crazy.
I'd be nine foot.
What was your goal for the Egyptian
vulture?
I'm going to have.
I'm going to have dreams about this
podcast.
That's its closest relative.
What the fuck?
Isn't it crazy?
That nature just designed a really
creepy,
shitty looking animal to come down and
eat all the dead shit.
Like that picture from right there.
MMM.
It looks old as fuck when it looks like
it could be in Nepal or Tibet.
Over hunting has led to the endangerment
of the species.
Hmm.
It's just um,
it's weird how nature has evolved these
animals or they have evolved to develop
this,
that weird look like vultures like look
disgusting,
but like,
look at that things face.
There's something about the way nature
has evolved or they have evolved and
they're not.
Yeah.
It's scary.
Cute animals are delicious.
Bright.
A rabbit?
Yeah.
Delicious.
Dear,
dear.
Delicious,
delicious,
gorgeous animals.
Right?
Like if you eat a bear,
like some people think bear acute,
but you got to cook the shit out of it.
Yeah.
Can we.
Let's address something right now.
Okay.
Bear meat is is good.
It's very good.
Yeah.
It can be depending upon what they.
Depending on what they eat,
where you're at.
Like if you're going in September to
Prince of Wales,
Alaska and you shoot one and it's just
been eating salmon for a couple of
weeks,
clams on the beach.
You don't want to eat that thing.
Right.
If you go somewhere where we're good
vegetation and it's,
it's well,
it's got a lot of fat on it.
It can be good.
I would argue it's not to be celebrated.
Like it's not that good.
It's,
it is not as well.
Depends.
Apparently if you eat a blueberry bear
is one of the best meats ever.
Yeah.
Never raves about for Nella does I?
I've had,
I've eaten a lot of bears and I like
eating them.
I'm not,
I wouldn't throw them away or whatever,
so I would continue to hunt them,
but I've never had that same feeling of
like an elp tenderloin or elk backstrap,
like it's just not an x or an access,
it's not in that category.
So I feel like maybe we overcompensate a
little bit because there's so much
pushback on bear hunting.
Right.
We started talking about how great it
is,
how great it is.
It's really good,
but it's not like it's not.
It doesn't get that next level.
Have you had smoked bear ham though?
I have.
That's pretty damn good.
But that's one of those things where
it's like it's smoked,
it's Brian treated us and that's the
biggest thing.
Right.
And you can most meats that you're going
to go hunting for,
you treat,
you look at the cut of meat and you
treat it accordingly.
Right.
And so there's no,
you have to obviously cut the chicken
gnosis you have to cook a bear all the
way through to a certain temperature,
so that may be b,
because I love rare meat.
That may be my problem.
I don't know,
but I think maybe I think maybe a little
bit we could address the fact that
hunters a little bit of over compensated
for the fact that people are pushing
back on them so much and that they're
like,
I love bear.
It's like it's good.
Right?
But I wouldn't choose it.
My favorite.
I wouldn't choose it over a lot of other
meats.
Right.
If you have bad,
but like if someone told me you have to
pick one animal forever,
I'd probably say elk and bear would be
pretty far down the list.
Wouldn't,
it wouldn't make it in the top three or
four?
It would be all.
Well that's again the thing that you
just said like I like eating things
medium rare or rare.
That's where they taste the best.
Yes.
Yeah.
And so like I'm not,
I would never put somebody down for one.
I love Barbie doll.
You did all the time.
That's great.
I just,
that's a point I've always thought in my
head,
I always thought in my head it's like
people like large mouth,
bass fishing,
but if you go to a restaurant and they
have large mouth bass right next to the
Chilean sea bass and you pick the large
mouth bass are kind of an outline to
yourself.
Yeah.
Like,
come on man.
Yeah,
it doesn't taste that good.
It's okay.
It's edible.
It's really good.
I mean if you took a poll because large
mouth bass tastes bear way better than
large
mouth bass for gay.
We're going down the track,
like large mouth bass just doesn't taste
that tastes better than large mouth
bass.
Large mouth.
No.
So.
Okay,
so delicious.
Fresh water fish.
Delicious.
Go to Alaska and they're everywhere.
Yeah.
Um,
but yeah,
I'm to,
I'm not much of a fish eater.
Anyway.
John Barklow from Sitka was in Vegas
this past weekend and we did.
Yeah,
he's a great guy.
Him and Dave brinker were there and he
was talking about how um,
I love that guy to leave Michigan.
Uh,
but John was talking about how he
actually enjoyed a brown bear meat and I
was like,
really?
And he's like,
he goes,
it tasted like a mule deer roast.
Like he goes,
I made it,
I gave it to people at parties and he
said he put it on,
like he cut it up into cubes and put
little toothpicks in it and handed it
out like as hors d'oeuvres at a party
and people are eating and they're like,
wow,
this is delicious.
What is it?
And he goes,
it's a brown bear.
And people got mad at him.
Of course they say it's a person.
I love that he did it.
I love that he did it though.
I support fully support that idea.
Right.
But I would assume that if someone like
John who works for [inaudible] is
probably the number one hunting gear,
clothing company in the world.
John is a wealth of knowledge all the
way through and you know,
had a considerable amount experience in
the military.
I would imagine the people that would
come to his house for a party would be
normalized to happened in La if you did.
If you did that,
God,
they go crazy.
Yeah,
there'd be a,
there'd be riots.
Yeah.
You should see the look on people's
faces when my kids tell them that
they've eaten bear because you know,
when the kids were like five and six,
like I've eaten.
I ate a.
It was awesome.
Do they have that like fierce look in
their eyes like you just had to bear.
I think it's fun to freak people out.
I do like that sausage and Doris Acute.
That's a wonderful thing coming out of
there.
It's weird,
right?
It's,
you know,
the bear thing is a very strange one.
And I um,
I definitely don't like hunting them.
Like I like hunting.
Anything else
I struggle with that.
Like I as a hunter,
I feel like coming on and talking as a
hunter,
I don't want to like disparate disparage
anything,
but I also just want to be 100 percent
honest about every part of it.
And hunting is really complex activity
and I feel conflicted about it almost
every time I go.
Like not about killing the enemy,
we're hunting,
but just about little parts of what's
going on.
Yeah,
and so bear hunting,
so sometimes you just want to like
Rinella said this once,
and I never understood it until it
happened to me.
He's like,
I just want to watch them.
Sometimes I don't really want to hunt
them and it's.
It's what is hunting anyway.
It's hunting,
killing or was hunting,
getting close enough to like shake their
hand saying,
yeah,
it's the whole thing.
I think my opinion on that specific
point is one I would go back to.
I always ask myself two questions,
why are you going and and does this
hunting benefit the place and the animal
that you're hunting and if I can't
answer those questions myself and I
always strip away conservation and meat
from the first question,
will you have a very good way of looking
at this?
I think is very honest.
I think this is super important is that
conservation is essentially a side
effect of hunting.
That's a byproduct and to pretend that
it's the whole thing,
it's almost like a weird.
It's,
it's a disingenuous approach to the
argument,
like really saying you shouldn't be
hunting will say,
well,
hunting is conservation and hunters of
the best conservationists.
Okay,
that's funny.
That's true.
But it's not as true,
but it's not really why you're doing
there.
And there's the,
here's the biggest point to make there
semantic chinks in that armor,
right?
We've built up over the years as
hunters.
They usually organic meat and
conservation as this like armor,
right?
That insulates why we go.
And I think there's just chinks in that
armor that if we don't recognize those
points,
especially the conservation,
when I think that's a bigger deal,
like conservation hunting is a tool for
conservation.
It's the same way as translocation is a
tool conservationist.
Um,
you can move the animal to get them away
from a certain situation,
uh,
reintroduce animal fats one way or bring
in hunters and help manage the
population that way.
But it's that first question,
right,
is why do I go?
And I always say it's like we've had
experiences,
you and I together in the woods that I
wouldn't,
we couldn't replicate anywhere else.
Like you've done a lot of cool shit and
there's some like when you ran down the
road after I shot my moods,
like there's just something about that
for me that is way more fulfilling and
enriching to my life than any other
thing I've experienced.
I haven't experienced everything,
but all the things that I've done well,
it's so primal.
Right?
And so it's that.
It's learning about animals.
You're in the woods too.
You're also in a really almost like
you're a visitor in an alien world.
Exactly.
And so you learn about these animals,
you,
you developed skills,
I feel like you wouldn't develop any
other way.
So and on and on it goes.
I mean there's probably a 100 reasons
that I and I discover a new one every
time I go.
And so I always say like that's the
answer to the first question,
why do I go?
It's not like,
man,
I'm real hungry and I want to control
the population.
I'm aware as I go hunting that the two,
those two things are byproducts of my
efforts,
then they're always going to be
byproducts of my efforts unless I'm
poaching.
Right.
You know,
I'm,
there is a biologist,
a state wildlife biologist,
federal biologists that determine what
tags go where,
what animals,
they're moving pieces of the puzzle
around to keep this thing the way it is.
Right.
Keep it healthy,
keep it stable,
but they're also looking at what's the
economic impact of that all that's going
on while I'm out there thinking I gotta
kill this big buck,
but I'm not thinking while I'm out there
with my bow,
I'm not thinking,
well,
I'd like to kill that one because
that'll really stabilize this area,
but I'm out there and kill that one
because I really liked backstraps.
I know those two things are happening,
but they're almost like be pulled that
away from,
from what's actually going on and focus
on why you're there.
Like,
why don't you go,
why did you go to Lanai?
Like what somebody said,
why did you go,
what would you say?
Two reasons.
One,
um,
to bowhunt for me for sure because I
want her to eat access to here and two,
because I think that it's great
practice.
One of the hardest things about bow
hunting is just you can practice all day
on a target,
but it's almost like never sparring.
Like you could practice all day hitting
a heavy bag,
but you've never had hit a person.
Right?
Like once you're in front of a person,
things get weird,
but when there's a chink in the armor,
right?
So you say,
I practice on an animal,
that's terrible.
I would say to that,
like that that's just another chink in
the armor that we all know is happening.
Like if we were conservation,
so we would never pick up a bill.
Yeah.
But I'm not practicing on an animal.
Look,
I've never practiced before.
Texting maybe be in the wrong term.
Like there's something in there that
like the experience of stalking an
animal is pretty visceral and if you've
never done it,
you shoot your back on the hell you
want.
Well,
I say practice in terms of like when you
compete as a a young martial artists,
it's not really practice,
but it is like you're involved in
competition,
so like are you hunting or are you
practicing?
We are definitely hunting,
but that hunting is practice for other
hunts or you don't get nearly as many
opportunities as you do in Lanai.
Lanai is one of the best examples of a
place that has no predators in a real
problem with overpopulation.
You were with me in Dudley that one time
where me and him and his son were were
hanging out and we were there at last
light and we were watching these access
deer come off the mountain and we saw
how many hundreds.
I mean it might've been seven,
800 deer coming off this mountain and we
were like,
what the fuck?
It was just crazy.
There's 10 more,
there's five more,
there's six more,
there's 11 more.
There's a herd of 20.
Like what the fuck?
It got to the point where like this is
crazy.
So in a place like that,
I feel like you have a,
a great ethical argument for like
they're going to shoot these animals,
period.
And the only other way to get around it
is you bring in wolves and if you bring
in wolves,
wolves,
and these people also have dogs running
around on the streets and like pet dogs,
those dogs that get fucked.
Like immediately they're going to get
killed by wolves.
Wolves want to take out all the
possible.
You can't have wolves on the NIH.
It's a stupid idea.
Let's,
hey,
everybody is stopped.
We're never going to do that.
But.
So it's one of it in terms of like since
since the animals are there and there's
no talk of eradicating them because they
have a real value.
The people that live there live off of
them,
like all those folks that we were
hanging out with,
like Romano,
a lot of the people that work at that
place,
they eat access all the time and it is
without a doubt,
not an oh,
it is the opposite of it is the most
delicious game me in the world.
If it's not,
if it's not,
if it's not number one,
it's number two.
It's amazing.
It's so good.
Like we hated it at the restaurant.
They served at a restaurant and remember
the burger
we had that one lunch.
Oh my gosh.
And then the state police,
the state place at that place.
Terrible.
Terrible meaning?
Good.
Terribly terrible.
Like,
Hey,
I can't get it out of my mind thinking,
oh yeah,
that's what it was.
They were sliders.
Yeah.
But that's the restaurant serves
tenderloin and it is phenomenal.
It's so good.
So why would I.
that's why one thing I always try to
separate and I try to do it only because
I think I try to look at it from someone
else who is a non hunter and is hearing
us talk or hearing me talk and whatever.
And maybe thinking like that's a weird
part of that.
Like,
that's strange.
And so I feel like if I can say yes,
the meat is delicious.
Yes.
They got to kill these things.
The local people value the animal
because hunters exist,
you know,
they,
they wouldn't just gun them down because
hunters will pay to go out there.
All those things.
I think set aside,
what am I there for?
Like we were that group of hunters we
had in camp was probably.
I mean I've hunted with a lot of awesome
talented folks,
was probably the most skilled group of
hunters I've ever been around when
thinking about who we have.
We have John Dudley is arguably,
if not the best bowhunter in the world.
He's in the top three.
I think it's like,
it's like John.
Well there's like top four,
like John Kamm,
Remy and uh,
Adam.
Adam Green Tree.
Yeah.
They might be all the people that funded
with that top four,
I would say.
I think they might be the top four in
the world and if they're not top four,
they're all during the top 10 cs.
If you think you're better,
come see us.
A clan of killers.
I mean,
and then you've got Shane Dorian is a
great bowl,
hundred two and it's a big wave surfer
in the world.
Say about Shane.
He's fanatical,
like he would just,
I'd be like,
Hey Shane,
you want to let go take a break and get
a sandwich?
And he'd looked at me like,
what?
Yeah.
He's like,
no,
we can be hunting.
Why would we be eating sandwiches?
He was out there all day,
every day,
all day.
Then he didn't come in during lunchtime
when everybody else was in [inaudible].
It was 95 degrees outside.
Yeah,
he's out there on his hands and knees,
crawling bushes.
It's crawling,
hoping to find one slip and this girl
just forever to crawl it for me.
Like one reason to do that,
stripping away all the things that I
know to be right.
Right in my own mind was that was those
people getting them all together?
Yeah,
and then like meat and Roman and me and
Brandon and meet Alec.
All our guides and all the locals that
were there,
like there's things I and I learned more
about the quick twitch muscle and the
gut,
dear.
Oh my God.
Than I've ever learned.
So I feel like I've learned something.
I spent time with these people that made
me better at not just hunting,
but everything.
Well for people who've never been around
and access to hear before they evolved
with tigers.
Tigers hunt them.
I mean,
you have never seen an animal more fast
in your life.
How about the one deer that we shot?
I shot this deer.
It was 60 yards away.
It was looking at me and I was like,
I think I'm going to shoot it.
It's just standing there.
By the time I got there,
it was four or five deer away.
It was swimming to Maui.
It was at a little.
It build a boat and it was over 60
yards away.
The arrows going 275 feet a second and
it was nowhere near it.
By the time it got there.
It's like,
please,
there's so fast.
They're fascinating.
Any animal I've ever seen.
Well,
would that lets you say like what a
weird scenario to be hunting an animal
that has been trained by tigers to
avoid.
You know,
what a weird thing.
So like that.
That's my appreciation.
That little,
that little exchange of,
hey,
me and tigers both hunted this thing,
like that's,
that's something cool to me,
that's a,
that's outside of this thing.
So talking about that all day with it
and then the meat.
Look if you're gonna,
if you're a person who values animal
protein,
if you like ethically sourced animal
there's no better way to get it than,
than like a place like Lanai,
like all the pieces are in check.
Do they need to kill them?
Yes.
Is there an overpopulation problem?
Provide jobs for local.
Yes.
Yeah.
All the good things.
I mean there's a lot of positive sides
to it.
Yeah.
And again,
if you're someone who enjoys bowhunting,
like,
look,
it's an uncomfortable thing for some
people,
but I enjoy it.
I like it.
I like getting my meat that way.
I don't like,
I feel bad if I get bacon from a store.
I feel like.
Are we talking about like a as
predators,
like we are predators.
If you look at,
you know,
it's been millions of years.
We've been killing eating things.
New humans are herbivores and that's all
a lie.
I don't know,
I've done some reading and Predator.
Look,
you don't have to be a predator.
You could live off of,
but aren't we though we up.
Some people.
Look,
you can live by point is if you want it
to.
I don't want to disparage away anybody
lives there live.
You could live off of just pure
vegetables.
You could live off it and by the way,
there's a real moral and ethical
argument if you are a Vegan to eat
mollusks folks because monologues are
more primitive than most plants.
They don't communicate as much as plants
do.
They don't have any sense of feeling.
They have no nerve endings that would
allow them to feel pain.
They're incredibly simple organisms.
The only thing that we have against them
in terms of like when we think about
them as being an animal versus a,
you know,
a plant.
People think eating a plant is cruelty
free.
Eating a mollusk you're killing a living
creature.
Right?
But that's just because they move.
But a fucking Venus flytrap moves to and
it's probably 10 times smarter than like
a scallop.
Like they're not smart.
It's hard to regulate that morality.
It's.
It is,
but I mean I just want people,
if you're,
if you're uncomfortable with eating
chicken,
I get it,
but clams and oysters and those things
are good for you.
They really are and it's sustainable and
the,
the animals themselves are not feeling
shit.
Yeah.
The moral entanglements of all of it is
just like we say,
we're,
we humans.
We wake up in the morning and you
consume everything like you just
consuming.
You breathe there.
You pump out CEO too.
I mean every other animal does too.
They just wander around on the grass and
consumption engines.
They're like for us to to separate out
one part of our consumption and then
beat the crap out of it.
Even though we've been doing it for 2
million years is in and of itself kind
of weird.
Well,
you know what I think happened.
Is your mic on?
That was a weird story.
Loud was weird.
It was like it was in my ear,
Davies,
Davies on the ride there.
They're getting crazy,
but I think part of the issue is that
people over the last hundred years or so
have been so removed from where the meat
comes from that when they can find a
direct connection like,
oh,
you went and you shot a moose and then
you ate that move.
So like you were,
you killed the Moose.
Like you didn't have to kill that Moose
like that.
That becomes problematic because people
aren't used to someone killing things.
Yeah.
People that they know in particular know
and I,
I enjoy the ideological conversation.
I just enjoy the conversation.
Right?
Like I enjoy it because I think it's
part of a human condition.
It's part of who we are and what we do.
So yeah,
we should probably fight about it a
little bit and disagree because it's
pretty damn important.
Like this is an important piece of our
humanity.
It is.
We're talking about.
So I,
I feel very strongly that hunting is
like the essence of who I am as a human
and has made my life better.
But I can see how somebody else would
say that's you're killing stuff I can't
do.
And I also think that those people are
important.
I think so.
I think having vegans and having animal
rights activists and having to be able
to have dialogue with them,
it also makes sure that you keep people
honest,
like people that are hunters like,
you know,
like,
because we all know unethical people.
There's people that are unethical.
Absolutely.
Look at it.
I always think about it,
you know,
if you look at the trend of hunting and
the seventies hunting was doing great.
And then in the eighties started to tick
down fucking Bambi.
That's what happened.
You.
Well I would say three.
We,
I,
we talked about this before,
like three things.
Bambi,
maybe Walt Disney.
He was maybe a Dick,
I don't know.
Uh,
and then urbanization,
right?
Which correlated with the client and
hunting.
And then hunters being the third one.
Messaging we have a bad were bad pr.
Some of them are bad pr agents and
people like Rinella that are amazing at
it.
We're way better now than we were five
years ago with better tomorrow than we
were yesterday.
But I think like in general,
like if you look at that line graph
right in the seventies,
it was going nicely in the eighties.
It started to decline and I think 2011
was the first time.
It actually went up.
A real number of.
I think it's the licensed sales or
number of hunters participating.
I wonder what caused the.
That's like the organic food.
There was a study that said locavores,
they're talking about more women.
They talked about returning military
members.
I'm around remembering reading the
study.
I think those are the top three.
But I think local Var was probably
pushed out there as like the way to
reverse that second point.
The way to reverse the suburban and
urban rise was to take that suburban a
male or female and say you can get your
food right.
And then that's a way to kind of reverse
the decline.
And I think that's probably what was
happening that well everybody wants to
go with locally sourced,
locally raised grass fed.
People are trying to go to farmers
markets and connect with the people that
are actually growing the animals.
And this is like one step better than
that,
instead of having an animal that's in
captivity,
go out into the forest.
But there's a rude awakening for a lot
of these people that think they're going
to just go ahead and try it.
Like it is not easy by any stretch of
the imagination.
The other problem,
it's the Grand Canyon being I would love
to.
I would love to procure my own elk meat
and killing an elk is like being on two
sides of the Grand Canyon.
Like you can't.
There's no bridge to be built there.
You got to take it one step at a time.
And for most people that's just not the
time for that.
They don't have the want to do that.
So I would say it was there like 14
million hunters in the world or
something like that.
Or in the.
In our country.
How many,
how many?
Non Hundreds.
You don't either have the wherewithal to
be,
to get educated or want to or just don't
fall into the anti on her side,
like the agnostic crowd.
How many of those are there out there?
I don't know,
but it's hundreds of millions of people
are,
you know,
there's a lot of them.
Urbanization.
One of the things it's done just just
careers,
careers in cities.
It's eliminated almost all of your free
time and if you wanted to go out and
procure your own meat,
first of all,
if you want to do with a rifle,
that's going to take a tremendous amount
of time,
but if you want to do it with a bow,
so multiply that by a factor of like
maybe five or 10,
maybe 10,
10 is probably pretty honest,
honestly.
And then you're talking about one of the
hardest pieces is access,
right?
So even if you.
If you get with John Dudley and you
learn how to be a great archer and you
understand that in your suburban area,
there are some places where there's deer
that you may kill.
You got to get access to those places
and then when you're done with that,
you've got to figure out a way to get
that thing from dead deer to meet and
all the other things.
So this is just so complex.
How would you ever expect somebody just
to be,
have like a desire?
You were like that at some point.
Well,
Rinella opened the door for me to have
that super lucky forever grateful
because when he took me into a wild back
country,
Montana.
Yeah,
you got gear in the nuts.
The first year there was a breaks in the
Missouri breaks in October nine degrees
out.
Freezing your dick off every night in a
tent,
but it like lifeless,
Steven Ella.
That's kind of what it's like and that
it.
He loves suffering.
He loves it,
but I love that he loves it.
He's legit as they come.
He really is.
I think that's it,
right?
There is just this,
there's this big gap and my father got
me into it but my brother doesn't.
Doesn't hunt and.
But I think he has a respect for it and
understands what's going on.
But he just,
I think at the time that I was
introduced to hunting,
my brother was more interested in going
out with his friends and Saturday
mornings were not for getting up early
and so we're essentially the same
person,
but I just went this way and he didn't
go that way.
Right.
So it's,
it's a weird.
So you could be in the same house with
somebody in a different way.
Well,
Rinella has a real good way of looking
at it too.
He's like,
uh,
I don't expect people to go out and get
rid of their own sewage.
Why should I expect them to go out and
hunt their own food like you don't have
to?
Well,
and he's,
I think he probably said this at some
point,
um,
or somebody smart did.
It was like I choose,
I believe,
that I choosed to meet to be the one
thing that I grabbed ahold of to bring
into my,
to my skill set.
I don't knit my own clothes.
I don't,
I don't make my own shoes.
I don't build my own houses.
You know,
we were just looking at some
construction stuff a little bit earlier.
I'm like,
dude,
I what?
Yeah.
What are they doing?
Yeah,
I couldn't do that.
I just picked this one thing because
it's also part of my passion.
So you couldn't just ask someone who's a
construction worker to go like,
go hunt,
get some mate.
I know you have a desire for that.
So that's just another hard part about
hunting and nonhunters by proxy are
essential to hunting always in industry
and opinion and because we could
legislate ourselves out of being able to
hunt that can happen is a privileged
man.
That's not a right and a lot of ways and
so that's another whole nother can of
worms,
but it could.
It could go away.
Yeah.
I think the.
The issue is that so many people are
opposed to it because they're so removed
from the realities of the wild and they
just feel some sort of moral superiority
by either not eating meat entirely or by
not killing their own meat.
The not killing their own meat is really
ridiculous.
Like my wife was having a conversation
with someone,
they were out to dinner with a bunch of
people while I was on an elk hunt in the
guy was eating a steak guy from England
in England and all hunt or they've do
hunting foxes and horses and shit.
And they were like,
tweed pussies England.
We love you guys carving a steak.
And my wife goes,
oh,
he's actually out elk hunting.
And the guy goes,
he hunts.
That's deplorable.
The guy said,
does deplorable while he's carving a
steak.
I was saying something the other day
and I got.
And I got a lot of,
like people were looking at me like I
was weird at work.
Uh,
one of my buddies that work was eating a
chicken sandwich from chick filet and I
look in the bag and there's a cartoon
chicken on the bag.
And in my mind I'm like,
well,
that's like building a swimming pool by
the lake.
That's fucking weird irony that that
were like saying,
Hey,
I'm eating the chicken,
but here's a cartoon version of it so we
can celebrate the fact that we just
murdered this chicken and we fried it up
like that doesn't make sense like a
swimming pool with a lake as smart
because it's Paris,
the braids wearing all the time for a
refill and it is weird.
That was.
You know what I mean?
Well,
we.
We definitely like to cartoon eyes.
These weird.
Is that a word?
Not really cartoon.
Personalize.
No.
Well,
anthropomorphize.
As you take an animal and you give it
human characteristics personify.
No cartoon of vacation.
Is that a word?
Just turning it into a fucking cartoon.
Green drinks.
We'll do what we want.
A sweet little cutie pie when really a
chicken is a ruthless little fucking
dinosaur that lays eggs for you
everyday,
but it isn't.
Is it weird to be eating a chicken and
like there is where that chicken came
from.
Yeah.
It's like a picture of the chicken.
So it kind of a.
seems like a weird way to handle it.
Well,
it is weird,
but we liked
cartoons.
People love cartoons.
Well that's like the personification of
animals I think is part of the bear
situation because my kid,
my son is nine months old and from
before he was born until now there's
cartoon bears everywhere and there's
like this,
you know,
personification of these cute little
creatures that come along with being a
little baby and then.
And then you look at so many a pixar and
dreamworks films at like personify
animals.
I think that's,
I mean it's,
there's some indoctrination into that,
right?
There has to be.
There is because in those,
those magazines or rather those movies
and books,
even those animals will never like
eating each other to.
I mean if,
if like,
if,
if he killed a hiker,
you know,
if a hike or fucked up on one of the
episodes of yellowstone and just took a
wrong turn and Yogis,
like eating his rib was bunch of people
show up and bear and yoga.
You're just going at it and ripping it
apart.
Eating cubs.
Yeah.
Eating some dude asshole first boys
screaming and swatting at it with his
fucking hiking in their plant,
in the circle of life.
In the background.
Yeah.
Well Go.
There's this.
I feel like there's some indoctrination
and maybe maybe that's what happens.
I just don't know.
I have no idea why bears get this thing
because bears are around.
It's not like there aren't barriers
around there in almost all states aren't
they?
Like,
yeah.
But it's what it is is people that don't
experience them firsthand and when they
do experience a firsthand,
usually they're in their car like local
bear and they drive by Tommy
that one bear that was walking on a
tight legs.
And that was cute.
Oh,
that one that had a broken front paws
with friends with that bear.
They called them like pedals or
something like that is awesome.
There was um,
my friend Tommy who lives in Connecticut
sent me a picture of these bears that
were in the middle of the street duking
it out in Connecticut.
Like they're invading Connecticut now
and they don't have any pressure.
So here's the thing about bear hunting
as opposed to anything else,
like California is weird in that they
don't hunt mountain lions.
But what's good about that is California
has very little deer now.
It's not good if you like to hunt deer,
but it is good if you like to drive down
the street and not slamming a fucking
deer.
Like Iowa doesn't have mountain lions,
but they do have a shit ton of deer.
And when you drive late at night in
Iowa,
you got to have your foot on the gas.
We're ready to hit that fucking break at
any second.
Just get that ranch hand guard garden.
He's mad.
Max Grill people like everywhere you
look.
And like Iowa and Montana,
these people have pickup trucks with
these battering ram front grill.
Things that they should I
deer.
We kill on alumni.
Were you in any of the deer?
Oh,
we must've hit a car.
Oh yeah,
with the Brandon's truck.
I think we hit at least two or three
deer.
Did you?
While we run the night,
we,
we were there.
Any romanza better driver than Brian
must be this.
What's going on?
And if you're listening,
we never handled tenant to.
We didn't even hit one.
Yeah,
we hit multiple,
but they were telling me about them.
They were like,
people just slamming,
you know,
I'm sure the insurance industry would
really enjoy will in Cape Town last year
a guy died because a guy in front of him
hit a deer and the deer flew through the
air and went through his windshield and
brain.
Dumb luck.
That's a shit luck.
Having a longer term story like that you
like,
I would have liked to hear that.
You're like,
I would have done duck as a pussy.
I'd have been like,
I don't know,
stupid shit like that.
Right.
I would have been driving my car and I
would have seen this deer flying through
there.
And I'm like,
well,
it was a good run.
Like there's,
there's nothing I can do about it.
It's been a good time and airborne dear.
That's just bad luck.
The 150 pound blacktail yeah.
Through the air.
What the hell?
Antlers and hooves I'd have been like,
well it was.
I lived all these years without this
happening.
That was lucky.
That's probably more lucky,
right?
Yeah.
Yeah,
but that's,
I mean,
you know,
you start to like break down those
things like more animals,
less animals,
the value of them and all these things.
What a complex freaking thing to have to
figure out.
I always just get more.
You read,
the more you jump in,
the more you go,
you know,
going to New Zealand,
go into,
in the northwest territories,
going in Nepal,
you go to these places and you just
realize that everybody has the same
essential problem.
Like how do we cohabitate,
how do we live with these things that,
that we were in some ways meant to
consume.
Like there's evidence of 2 million years
ago in Tanzania,
a human's early humans hunting and so
100,000
generations of people have a sense have
lived on the hunter gatherer diet.
You know?
Then you had the industrial revolution,
couple generations of people kind of
were introduced to a new diet and then
the last couple of generations you have
processed foods and so you.
Everywhere that I've ever been,
you find people are struggling with that
thing.
It's like it's just not us in America,
right,
but when you can exist on a plant based
diet,
I mean,
I know a lot of people literally
absolutely can be done and I'm sure in
those 100,000
generations there was plenty of people
that didn't exist on the hunter gatherer
diet alone,
but the majority of money there were
honestly because I feel like people were
just really super optimal opportunistic
back then.
I mean if you were just trying to
survive and struggle,
I don't think you would say like,
Hey,
I don't want to eat that rabbit.
Rabbit is the way I live,
and then you have to only where it's
spelled and the left.
That's a different deal.
I was writing a piece one time and then
I got into reading about these.
A basket weaver,
people that were in the valley of fire
state park in Nevada,
which is really close to Vegas
and you should go if you've never been
up there.
Basket weavers.
Yeah.
Basket basket maker or a basket weaver
people and they're like native
Americans.
Yeah.
They were essentially a roving band of
nomadic hunters.
I don't.
I can't think of the year,
you probably look it up and find it,
but there was different generations of
this essentially roving band of tribes
in that area.
Next time you're in Vegas,
it's like an hour drive north.
There's a bunch of petroglyphs that
depict like dvds and and sheep and all
these different things there
and you can just go visit them.
What's fucked up about those
petroglyphs?
Man,
they're not protected like there's a
ranch in Texas that a buddy of mine went
to and he's like,
you could just go over there and touch
these things and they might be 5,000
years old.
I did that when my wife and I went up
there.
You could have add a can of spray paint.
They weren't like,
how fucked up is that?
It's strange.
It's strange that you wouldn't find a
way,
but also probably.
Yeah,
it's probably okay because it's a
natural occurring.
You know,
this is a natural place.
You want to put fences up or no guard
standing there.
So what solutions?
Pretty bad ass that no one's
so far.
Well,
and so you'd go up there and you see
these things and you're like,
holy crap.
So I started reading a little bit about
those people and they were a part of a
nomadic,
a band of hunters,
gatherers that lived in caves and
essentially followed a desert bighorn
sheep,
much like a end user.
The planes followup buffalo.
All right?
So they were,
they essentially follow these things
into this valley.
Eventually the Anasazi Anasazi Indians
move in,
they start cultivating the land and
planting crops and you get this like,
oh my Gosh,
agriculture and hunting,
which one is better?
What do we do?
And so the whole story of that
interaction,
uh,
is interesting to me because it's kind
of the evolution of our culture,
right?
Hunting is created this social structure
wise for us to communicate.
It's created all these things,
ways for our body to grow and expand as
we were,
you know,
early humans,
a waste for our brain to expand and grow
and function differently.
And then you have this like,
oh,
it's a lot easier to plant crops in the
ground than it is to go kill a sheep.
Right.
Guys,
anybody is this easier,
so then you get into this weird thing
like what do we do now?
You know,
and so I think their,
their story was very much like the
Anasazi Indians,
they go in and they cultivate this area
and as long as they can grow crops,
that's what they did,
you know?
And so this nomadic band of hunters kind
of settled in this area and so I'm sure
they still wanted to get me because they
have to because you can't grow a whole
year's worth of food for,
for a value like that.
But I think agriculture kind of won out
a little bit in that,
in that scenario and as it would,
it's easier way to live.
Yeah,
it's an evolutionary.
What?
Easier way.
I mean the whole thing is filling your
belly.
That's the whole thing.
And everything you know,
you can do to do it,
whether it's with deer or whether it's
with corn or whether it's with tomatoes
or whatever.
You can grow and you know,
you just have to eat.
I mean that's,
that's the whole,
the whole picture is staying alive back
then.
That's not whole picture today,
so that's where it gets really
complicated and that's where I think
that hunters have done a really good job
over the last x amount of years
describing to people like,
if you're going to eat meat,
this is the most ethical,
the most cruelty free and the most
natural way to do it.
And you're talking about an animal that
literally like,
okay,
here's a perfect example.
That deer mule deer that looking at
right here,
that deer had no idea I was alive until
it died and it died instantly.
It was boom,
one shot,
it dropped right where I shot it,
and that's it.
And then it becomes steak,
you know,
and it becomes delicious food that we
ate.
And that's uh,
that's way better than any other animal
that you're ever going to buy in the
store.
I don't care if you're talking about
farm raised,
grass fed,
you know,
locally,
I feel like your evolution as a hunter
has been accelerated more than most
practices.
That's how you do everything.
But you went from,
when I first we first hunting in British
Columbia was three,
three years ago to where you are now.
You've evolved in this like what you see
as hunting and in our community and in
our world and doing different things.
Um,
and in some ways you evolve from when I
was a kid,
we just shot deer.
Oh,
here's the spike,
here's a four point shot this deer.
And that was a great day.
We drag it off and eat it and it's
great.
Now.
I understand way more about what I was
doing then and what I'm doing now.
And I think what at hunters we need to
be cognizant of and comfortable with is
you changed your sensibilities.
Change over time.
You don't become a trophy hunter,
you're not a trophy hunter,
but you do appreciate the difference
between a small antlered an animal and a
large one as it terms of its maturity
and how awesome it is to see a 380 inch
elk or 200 inch deer.
You know,
you,
you're pursued is different than it was
when we shot that Moose.
It is also.
But the also part of the pursuit is
different is that I understand that the
benefit of going after mature animals is
if you're getting a mature deer,
you're talking about a deer that's five
years old,
that deer has had five breeding seasons,
has spread its genes,
and by killing it you're going to give a
chance to the younger bucks to that are
coming up to breed.
So it's done.
It's part,
it's spread,
it's jeans,
it's created its progeny,
and now you'll take it out of a mix.
And this is the right way to do it
because then you ensure a healthy herd
that like,
especially for bear,
that's the big argument.
You want to take out the dominant males
because the dominant males actually eat
the cubs marauders,
animals.
That's the craziest part about it is by
shooting a bore,
you're going to save the lives of many
bear.
Yeah,
it's a week in many ways.
It's kind of a catch 22 because you're
talking about controlling.
Well isn't uh,
isn't a catch 22 that the,
uh,
younger deer tastes better.
Yeah.
And so like you're out there like I
really love access to your meat,
but to it when we're over there they're
like,
we have certain call box and there
certain things you want to shoot.
It's like I really access to your and
if,
if I was out there just for me,
I would have shot the youngest,
probably not the youngest,
but I would've picked a certain age
group.
And here's the argument against that
with axis deer,
that deer I shot was not young.
That was a big ass dinner and that
fucking things delicious dishes.
Like they're better than that when
they're younger.
I don't need that.
It's a fact that a younger animal is
more tender and is a better,
better cut of meat than an older animal
for sure.
In most cases.
Not all cases,
but that's the general.
That giant elk that I shot where you saw
the antlers.
They're all delicious.
That's amazing.
I've been eating that thing for eight
months now.
It's fantastic.
Yeah.
I do the same thing,
but I.
elk is great no matter what.
Yeah.
Animals.
You're talking about two animals that
it's hard.
It'd be hard to mess it up,
but in general that's the,
that's the matter,
right?
Since there's that argument though,
you know why I don't like that argument.
I don't mind chewy meat and I like,
I like eating what I kill,
so like it feels good to me on top of it
tasting good.
Like if I eat a deer that's a six year
old deer.
There's two things going on there.
One,
there's a satisfaction that I know the
six year old is very difficult to hunt.
Yes.
You know,
so most of the places where you have
other people are hunting as well.
A six year old deer has seen people that
are hunting deer period.
That's right.
So that deer is going to be on point.
That's a tough deer to kill.
So by killing that deer,
you get extra satisfaction.
That's one.
And then on to you,
you're,
you're eating this animal that you have
this connection with.
So it tastes good because of that.
And I'd like.
I like meat that tastes like me.
I don't want like Philemon Yon,
you know,
I like,
I like a deer steak,
you know,
like,
uh,
the best a sirloin from a mule deer.
I'd prefer that.
Well,
I would say like if you took
conservation and organic meat,
right?
And you said,
I'm going for.
I understand both those principals.
I'm going hunting.
Everything's great.
You're shooting that six year old mule
deer,
right?
If you,
if you remove conservation,
you're probably not going to shoot that
six year old mule deer because you're
going to get a younger deer that's
easier to kill,
more tender,
more delicious.
Drink and shoot that.
Bartow Garcia,
the chef and the Montana.
Yeah.
He,
he gets shit from other hunters because
he'll shoot a spike on purpose.
He's like,
look,
I'm here for the meat.
Yeah.
As he goes,
I'm grocery shopping.
That should be in general.
That should be okay.
But there's principles that say like the
shooting them mature animal is more
beneficial to the hurt.
So that's yet another complexity that we
should all just say like,
man,
this is here.
Just gotTa.
Continue to talk about it.
That's important.
I think the way you approach is very
important because you're entirely honest
about the good and the bad and the bear
thing.
You know,
like it's like it's not the best meat.
It's good man.
It's good,
but it's not as good as elk.
Yeah.
I'm not going to stand up and be like,
Hey,
policies mean to bears the best thing
ever.
It's not.
Some people love it though.
I don't know if they're telling the
truth.
They're telling the truth,
but it's just.
I'm just.
I would assure them if they would dabble
other mates,
they'll find that's better.
I'm pretty sure.
Well,
I guess it depends entirely upon the way
they prepare it,
but the thing about this,
an argument for hunting bears is
different than the argument for hunting
any other animal because you do eat them
and you need to kill them because they
don't have a natural predator.
The problem with bears is like,
especially if we went in Alberta,
Jesus Christ to the art everywhere,
people to think there's a shortage of
bears need to go to Alberta.
The people that want to have one of
those experiences where you walk away
from that and be like,
did I just do that?
Yeah.
They're 20 fucking bears hanging out
over there with cam like I wish we get.
Can Call Cam Cam please text in.
He's at work right now.
Quit your job.
Quit your job cam and telling you for
years.
Quit your job.
You're too cool to have a nine to five.
Uh,
it's,
he's got a 75.
Oh,
the Lord takes two hours.
Launched to go workout and run the
mountains.
Well,
that's savagery.
This savagery.
He does
good.
Seven to five Scott.
Damn savage do.
I'm not going to get my ass together and
he's a legit savage.
I know every time I'm complaining about
anything to think about campaigns
getting up at 4:00
in the morning to run with show,
think about that like 190,
eighth mile,
205th.
He's going to do 2:30
for the summer.
It only gets worse.
My Dad was an ultra marathon runner
growing up and it just gets worse.
It's like smoking crack.
Oh,
they just get deeper into your grandma's
door.
I,
that's probably a terrible analogy,
but I'm scared of it because I keep
running further and further distances.
I'm like,
what am I doing?
And I'm doing it more and more often.
What am I doing?
You're,
you're feeling a runner's high.
Well,
it's a little bit of that,
but it's also like I feel improvement
and I'm a improvement junk.
Yeah,
I know that I can keep pushing further.
I'm going further distances.
I feel better when I hit the top of the
hill.
Yeah.
Well my dad like,
well,
when I was a kid I remember my dad just
being a regular,
he must have been mid forties,
maybe late forties and he mowed,
we had like a fairly small backyard and
he mowed a little circle and he would go
out after work in his jeans and his
loafers and like jog around the circle
and it was very like.
I remember looking out there being like,
what are you doing man?
How big was he hard?
It was like maybe an acre,
I don't know.
It would very big and he was running
like just little circles in this yard.
Let me get to the end of the story.
You'll,
you'll get it eventually.
But that was,
that was his way to run.
Right.
And so after a while he started running,
you know,
got running shoes and started to get
into the actual sport of running and
then it seems to me like three or four
years later he was like,
I think I'm going to run this 50 mile
race in the mountains of Maryland,
JFK,
50 miler.
And had he run marathons?
No,
no.
So 50 mile races.
Like what?
It was like six hours,
seven hours a year.
Eight or nine hours.
I think.
Eight or nine.
I think when you started or maybe 10.
I think 12.
The
cuddle.
Interesting.
Like eight hours for 50 per for a
hundred.
It's 24.
Of course it is.
It's like listen bitch,
75.
But my dad used to run.
He used to run and places it was like
the JFK,
$50 up over this mountain.
It's not like I remember you telling me
stories of people falling and like
busting themselves all up on these rocky
cliff trails and he would come in and
this is gonna make my dad sound weird.
He's not,
he's,
he's awesome.
But he would save his toenails.
All his toenails would fall off during
the race and he like save them,
putting them in a little jar.
Memories he save his boogers to.
No,
no,
just toenails.
Uh,
and it was almost like this,
like I can take that lack this thing.
And then he went,
ran 50 and then I think one time we ran
a hundred and then he ran the entire c
and o canal one time,
183 miles.
And I was like,
I think it was in maybe a senior in high
school and I had had to drive to the
checkpoints and like give him food and
stuff.
He never started until he was in his
forties guy,
maybe fifties,
forties,
probably I would say.
Yeah,
like sorties.
Did He,
does he still do it?
How old is he now?
He would still do it if his knees would
allow him to.
He's mid sixties.
60 five is nice.
You're fucked up.
But he's still.
He's.
He'll still bike and he'll still.
He hikes all the time now so we still
has that like need to push push and he
like when he gets around,
one of his buddies in particular that
they ran together,
they're like old army buddies and
talking about this experience that they
shared together like remember that one
time a mile,
mile 94 when you tripped and fell and
it's just like they're telling old war
stories.
It's like this visceral thing that they
share.
It's really cool.
He did it passed.
I mean maybe it's a midlife crisis man.
I don't know,
but yeah,
he wasn't predisposed to run 100 miles
until he decided that he wanted to.
Yeah.
It's weird,
right?
That,
that,
that compulsion is a very odd one that
the need for suffering.
Like Cam's got it bad,
it becomes a thing.
Yeah.
He's got a bat in a weird way.
Or my dad,
like he got a knee surgery and then
like,
well they said it was a acl.
I think it was.
Or it was the scope of his knee.
He had an eastern scope scope.
It's an easy one.
But what if they cut his knee open?
Can't remember what.
I don't want to say the wrong one,
but he had knee surgery and they're
like,
give it four or five days before you're
up and moving around.
And he was like joking around the
backyard on day two,
limping around.
Just you could just tell he was in pain.
Oh,
that must have been meniscus.
Yeah.
Something like that.
Some tendon of some sort,
but it was just like,
you could just see this.
This dude is.
This is.
If you can't do this man,
it's not good for his psyche.
If he can do it,
he's a happy guy.
Well,
there's something that happens to you
when you push yourself like that where
it makes regular life easier and that's
part of the addiction.
It's real.
When I went to Nepal,
man,
that's exactly why I came back.
I was like,
I brought back a sheep I killed and all
that stuff,
but perspective as what you were telling
me how you were hallucinating,
baby.
I did.
Tell me about that.
Right?
How high were you?
We got,
we'll have to.
We were there.
We were like 13,000,
maybe 13 years.
13.
Five at 13,000
feet above sea level and so it's sketchy
as fuck.
It's sketchy.
It's not something to mess around with.
I found that especially on this trip,
so we were hunting blue sheep in Nepal,
Belushi,
Belushi.
What does that look?
Look it up.
Kind of like an all dad.
It's got these little.
Wow.
It's got really,
really.
You can really see their annual.
I like the.
The age rings and their horns.
They go straight out the short and
stocky.
It'd be cool to look at them.
They were cool animal and it's one of
those things where we went to hunt him
and I didn't really have much of an idea
of what blue sheep was until until we
started getting into the thing.
There's one.
Oh Wow.
Morales.
What they call me over there.
Wow.
What a cooler can animal.
Yeah.
Mine wasn't quite that big and that one
looks like it might be at a farm,
but uh,
because it's mowed grass and then maybe
we don't to go mow the grass.
That looks like more.
I saw a very disturbing video of a goat
eating a whole bucket of chicks.
I'm a little baby.
A baby chickens?
Yeah.
It was on.
What were you watching?
It was on an instagram page.
I think it was either was a Jimmy Jew or
clown in the homie.
Yeah,
that's it right there.
Look this fucking goat.
So I was just sitting there eating.
This is on a youtube.
And what's the name of the video?
Jamie.
They're amazing.
Goat eating live alive baby chicken.
So there's these two.
There's several bins of baby chicks and
this Ngo is just standing there and it
just reaches in,
choose one down and the goats aren't
carnivores so they don't have the teeth
for this and this thing.
This baby chicks trying to fucking
clawed its way out.
It's we'll get as much as he reaches in.
Oh,
he's just like,
I'll get one.
Oh,
I can't catch it.
We lost that one.
That one lived.
Look,
he gets one.
Here we go.
I got your bed.
She's just started doing.
Just started chewing like what?
What is happening with this one?
Wild Impala.
Fights back is its guts.
Fall out and feel like you're really
making the case for Christ.
Predator hunter.
Yeah.
Look at this.
This will know Paula is getting chewed
apart by this wild dog.
Oh my God.
Do it.
Don't stop it.
Oh my God.
But it's just.
It's in the cavity.
Oh Jesus Christ.
That's like where the Bacon is.
Oh God.
Oh Africa.
You're a dirty mother.
Look at this.
This,
and Paul was like,
come on,
let me.
I'm stabbing you motherfucker.
I know I got weapons.
I'm like,
look at your tail.
Oh,
look at this show down.
This is guts are literally hanging out
to the ground and it's standing up.
How tough are these things,
man and I.
I mean,
I would not want to get gored by that
impala.
Oh,
horn.
The dog doesn't neither.
Are they on a road?
Yeah,
they sure are.
There's a road right there.
Paved road.
We kind of just circles him to.
We can attach them on the flank.
Isn't it just messed up like wolves and
coyotes?
They hit the back legs first.
That caused that shock and blood loss.
I'm a big fan of cats because least cats
will grab you by your neck.
This motherfucker is not doing that.
This is weird.
There's a whole minute 30 left of this.
Yeah.
Oh,
there's more.
More come in and he's like,
that's it.
That's a wrap on.
They just grabbed the guts like how much
more has fallen out now?
Oh,
how can it be alive?
I have no idea.
I don't understand.
And they just go in after the leg.
Here comes another one.
Yeah.
Oh No.
It doesn't know what to do,
man.
Oh God.
We're having some Vegan.
Oh,
dinner too.
Just like what?
Six of them.
Three,
seven,
seven.
It's dead.
Now.
Look at that chunk.
Oh,
they just pulled the guts out and one
watching.
Look how fast they tear that fucking
thing.
Look at that.
It's just body cavity.
Now.
Holy Shit.
Did they drag the head off man there no
jokes.
And those guys are nothing compared to
hyenas.
Yeah,
it's hard out.
There is the point.
Like if you get hit by an Arrow,
it's way better than that.
Folks was like three minutes of terror.
Yeah.
We're going for the vitals were going
for double lungs or a heart.
It's going to end nicely.
Is the biggest part with the Internet.
You get from like,
what's a blue sheep to that shit too?
Yeah.
Will you?
You can go way deeper than that,
you know?
Yeah.
I saw it.
Got Chopped his dick off the other day.
What I would.
Yeah,
I,
I just for a Goof,
I um,
was looking at different hashtags online
and I look for Hashtag triggered.
I think I might've wrote Hashtag
triggered in something.
So I look for Hashtag triggered thinking
I could find a post that I wrote.
Oh good luck.
There's millions.
You're always.
One of them was this one dude chopping
his own dick off and they somehow or
another got on instagram and I was like,
how did that.
Nobody,
nobody caught it before they pulled it
down.
Look,
there's no way they can take down
everything.
Fucked up.
There's hashtagging it though.
That's savage thing.
The guys were like,
they were like,
well,
we're getting ready to get this done.
What do we do for the Hashtag
[inaudible] that's.
We got to market it.
Like we got to have people triggered.
Trick.
Hashtag triggered.
Yeah.
They have to market it.
Isn't that funny?
Marketing marketing is a big thing,
right?
You know what I was reading some
mutilation,
some fucking youtube,
not even youtube.
Rather.
Some instagram person was talking about
um,
what they do to market their brand and
all.
They were like,
I like a fitness person.
And I was like,
get the fuck Outta here man.
You have a brand,
you have 10,000
followers.
Are you a brand or you just some dude
who does squats Tuesdays,
arms and back.
That's my brand,
my brand,
my brand marketing team,
working hard on my brand.
It's like those,
those,
those kind of phrases,
people use those a lot and they won't do
something because it's off brand.
That's even a lead.
That's an extra level of Douchey brand.
Like I won't put that up because it's
off brand for me.
Who was like my brand,
right,
exactly.
That'll fuck with putting out there.
Seems quite preposterous.
Social media.
So tell me about seeing the baby and the
polio.
Let me finish.
So you're looking for.
Yeah,
so we're looking for the blue sheet.
So I'll start off by saying that we were
hunting in a very rural,
when I say rural,
it's like six days walk from the nearest
road where we were at the days and I
said how many days walk to the paved
road and they were like we don't,
I don't know what you're talking about.
Like we don't know we could engage that.
And so we're in this remote region in
Nepal,
the in this district called the
[inaudible] district.
And to say that the road from district
is full of this,
like primal primal people and animals
and it is really just out their place.
I think,
you know,
to be out away from civilization.
That was the furthest I think you could
feel.
I mean,
we were out there and the people,
the people there were part of a civil
war,
the Nepali civil war from 1996 to 2006.
This district was maybe the epicenter of
the rebellion.
There was a Communist Party rebelling
against the government.
We can step monarchy and so the people
there are,
are amazing because they've lived in
this abject poverty for their entire
lives and not only that,
they've lived through this civil war in
recent times.
I think we think about civil wars,
this thing we go to see a national park.
Um,
so anyway,
we're,
we're with these people were hunting.
We go into,
we get helicoptered into 10,000
feet,
which is this knob in the middle of
nowhere.
We hike about a full day to our base
camp,
which is a little village called dual
arc in the middle,
of course nowhere.
It's like this terrorist village and we
meet our Sherpas and,
and made a bunch of locals.
And from there we go up.
We're going to do,
I think we had two or three more days of
hiking just to get to the area where the
blue sheep live,
so you're hiking from about 10,000
feet and I at our highest,
we're at probably 16 or 16 and some
change and so the first day we go up and
we acclimate.
We site in,
our rifles were hanging out and we go
into this lady's little mud,
dirt hut.
Essentially.
It's just like probably half the size of
this room with a little with a goat
standing in the corner and a little fire
pit sitting around this fire pit and
they start.
She starts telling this story about how
right where we were sitting during the
rebellion,
the police,
the government police came in and shot
six men right where we were sitting and
buried him out back and this is like,
this lady must be in her mid fifties and
she.
She looked like she was 80.
I mean,
she's just like this.
It was this transformative thing for me
sitting there listening to this being
translated like,
holy crap,
where are we?
And in the midst of that store,
they're passing around.
They had made this moonshine,
which they called Roxy.
It's just like made in a ceramic thing
outside of where we were at.
And so we were all just drinking and I
wasn't thinking much about drinking it.
And then we had one more day before we
left.
The next day everybody was sick,
but me,
I'm talking shit,
your pants puke out the tent.
We had two or three people,
shit their pants the next day.
Like it was the,
the Katmandu flu.
Like everybody,
everybody that wasn't native to that
area got sick.
I didn't on the first day.
So everybody recovers.
The next day we're going up the
mountain,
we're going up.
We'd probably climbed about 2000 feet.
We go over this pass and I'm feeling
good.
I feel like everybody else was probably
feeling pretty crappy.
Then we're going down this ravine and
this river valley to go.
We're on these like two or three foot
wide goat trails probably.
It's like if you go to the right,
you're dead.
If you stepped two feet to the right,
you're going to die.
You're dead.
You fall off and you're dead.
We've got 24 Sherpas,
porters,
we've got three or four mules with all
our camp gear going up this mountain and
a string of people,
probably 30 people long.
I'm in generally in the middle and we
stop at some point after we had crested
this high point and we're going down and
I remember feeling pretty good.
I got my trekking Poles,
I'm going,
it's warm outside and I'm going.
I'm like enjoying the view and looking
around just thinking,
oh my God.
And then I.
Then I remember pretty quickly being
laying in the snow like,
Oh,
I'm laying in the snow.
That's cool.
Like I had no recollection of how I got
there.
What was happening at like.
So you're hiking and then when you wake
up I was laying.
I don't know that I lost consciousness,
but I just didn't.
I don't think in my mind I understood
what was going on.
Like I kinda stumbled back against this
rock wall and then just slumped down in
the snow.
I don't think anybody saw it.
And so I kind of stood up and I'm like,
you're okay.
You're good,
you fell down,
whatever,
maybe getting a little weird and I keep
going and we had a little problem with
the mules.
These mules,
we were going over the snow pass in the
mules,
couldn't get through it,
so they had to turn these meals around,
send them back.
They couldn't get through it because the
snow's.
Yeah,
I got videos of,
of snow's too deep and you're talking to
trail half as wide as this table.
Maybe they're trying to get these and
you're,
you know,
a thousand feet down to the river.
And so I,
we stopped,
we all stopped a second time to let
these meals go back by.
And like I had to hang onto a bush on
the side of the trail as they went by
and I got back up on the trail.
You're hanging onto a bush for dear
life.
I mean you could,
you had footing,
but we had,
we had filmmakers with us that we're
doing all kinds of crazy shit.
Like hanging off,
hanging off cliffs and doing stuff.
I will make a video.
Yeah.
To make film.
They were um,
and so we stopped.
We start going again,
most everybody gets out in front of me.
I was slowing up and I'm feeling dizzy
and I'm like,
man,
okay,
maybe I just stood up too fast.
Probably didn't eat enough today.
I'm going,
we're going.
And at some point I just like snapped in
the room was just like spinning like
crazy.
And I was thinking and I knew about
altitude sickness and I knew that I live
in a place that's basically sea level
and I was at a place that was 13,000
feet and I've never done that before and
prepare for it at all.
He should have can.
I mean there's not really any.
I trained.
I did for about.
We didn't really know we were going to
go until later.
So I trained for about a month and a
half.
Um,
but not a,
you can't train.
Like there's no.
They told me before we go,
like altitude sickness,
there's no predictor.
You could be a rookie or you could be a
veteran.
You can get it like that.
Like,
it's just,
it's part of the way your brain loses
oxygen at those altitudes and it's,
there's no real predictor for it.
And so I don't think physically I was
having any problems but so,
and I don't know that I had altitude
sickness,
but anyway,
the effects were I kind of sat down and
I just couldn't go anymore because I
couldn't get,
I wasn't about to walk on this trail and
I couldn't,
it stand up.
Right.
And so our medic slash interpreter slash
producer Cameron,
I'm Ben [inaudible] comes back to me and
starts talking to me through.
He's,
you know,
this dude's climbed everywhere.
I've been everywhere,
um,
and as a medic.
And so he's talking me through a little
bit of the situation.
He's like,
this is not good.
Like if you're too lazy to walk,
no good.
So let's get some water in you.
Let's rest,
let's get some food in.
You see what happens.
The meanwhile up the valley go to the
rest of the crew to,
to the next camp.
So him and I spent like 20 minutes just
going really slow and I just couldn't do
it.
I was like,
I can't stand up dude.
I can't catch my,
I can't get my head to get back on my
shoulders.
And so we sit down and we're sitting
there and uh,
I look across this little bowl in this
valley and I see this wolf.
I was like,
oh,
cool man,
that's wolf.
Get my binder is out.
I'm looking at,
I can't find it.
Put them back.
We'll go over.
And I was like,
Ben both over there and I see like,
I see it as like,
it's laying down.
He goes,
Shit.
I was like,
crap,
there's no wolves here man.
I was like,
oh my,
there's no wolves and all of Nepal.
He's like,
you're not gonna.
See a wolf?
Fear basically don't exist.
They don't exist where we were in that
district,
in the,
in the hunting area where we were.
It's like,
it's not,
nope.
So you were hallucinating.
I was hallucinating,
but it was not one of those like you see
it and then you shake your head and it's
gone.
It was like a looking at it and it was
just this,
like what?
It could have been stumped,
but in my mind it was a freaking wolf.
What else?
Losing my shit a little bit at that
point I'm like,
this is not good.
And so then I'm sure in his mind he's
thinking diamox is a,
is a pill you can take to help with
altitude sickness and he's thinking
about,
okay,
are we helicopter and this guy out of
here on day two out to what are we going
to do?
Because it's,
you know,
not,
pulmonary edema,
cerebral edema.
That's nothing to mess around with.
It was only day two.
It was,
yeah.
Well Day two of the actual trip.
We were four or five days into being in
Nepal,
but they too have the,
the trick in.
And so we sat there for awhile and I
like I just look in and I remember just
looking after like 10 minutes,
it's still being there.
This is not good.
And so we get up to go and I'm like,
I can do it man.
I'm going to do it because I don't want
to leave.
I want to hunt and we get going a little
further down this trail and at this
point I'm trying to like find some
levity in the situation.
Joking with him.
He's joking with me.
We're just like trying to be normal and
when I know that my head's not normal,
we're going real slow and I look on this
side hill of this trail and there's a
fucking baby
that's.
I thought come on baby.
Like I didn't say anything to Ben about
naked.
I feel like it was a really big naked
baby if I didn't have a diaper on how
big the biggest meet me.
Like it's like 30 feet tall.
I don't know Joe Dark Shit we're getting
into.
It was,
it was an unusually saw.
It was like a baby that
if you saw it on the street you'd be
like,
Whoa,
what a whopper.
That's a serious baby.
Science should be studying.
Got It.
And get that big babies is on the side
of the.
And so I'm thinking like,
I'm not saying nothing to band because
this baby is like my ticket at home.
Like this baby.
If I'd be like,
baby right there,
you'd be like q,
the chopper.
Right.
See you buddy.
You can't make it sense.
It wasn't like the wolf.
It wasn't like I saw it and I stared at
like,
I saw it and then I looked back and it
was there and I looked back and wasn't
there.
So I kept going.
I'm like,
you know what baby,
if you're really there,
fuck you.
You shouldn't be up here anyways.
It's not my fault.
Like,
wow,
you got a harsh harsh with the fake
baby.
The fake baby.
I'm just going,
man,
I'm not.
Whatever baby.
Stay there.
Wow.
So I didn't say anything to Ben about
the baby,
like right off and we're getting going
and eventually I just kind of collapsed
and I'm like,
look man,
I,
you know,
I was talking positively and I wasn't
hallucinating anymore than the baby and
the wolf,
which is enough and we get down,
we get going down this ravine and camp.
You can start to see camp guys put in
camp together.
And um,
essentially he's like,
just give me your pack,
community trekking,
Poles giving everything.
And he held my shoulders and just kind
of one step,
one step,
one step for a solid hour and a half or
so until we got to camp.
A lot of breaks,
a lot of just him and I talking about,
well here's the scenarios.
Are you,
is this really,
you know,
is it acute mountain sickness or are
you,
you know,
what's going on sick like the other
people got so yes.
So that happened the next day.
So the next thing it was because of
drinking that moonshine.
I think we got sick because of the
moonshine.
It could have been water in Katmandu it
commit to anything or how are they
making that moonshine?
I have no.
I have a picture of it.
I show you like it.
It was,
it looked like in this big ceramic
thing.
It's probably a bit.
Goat was walking over there licking out
of it,
but we all did it.
Everybody in there got some level of
sickness that wasn't used to that area.
It wasn't used to being in Nepal and
eating food and drinking the minutiae
and all that.
So who knows?
It was the moonshine that was behind
getting it could've been any.
So we finally make it to camp and we're
doing a film,
so they're filming me while I'm all
messed up and I was kind of out of it.
I mean we're coming down this switchback
trail to go into camp and I remember
like not I much like when I fell I was
like,
I'm aware that my feet are hitting the
ground and these trekking poles are
hitting the ground and like I'm aware
that I'm doing this,
but I feel like I'm,
I can't control it.
I feel like I could be floating through
the air just as well as walking.
He a weird like head detached from body
feeling.
Wow.
It was gnarly and I'm at the end of the
day,
I think what they thought was like it
was the sickness that everybody else got
coming on at the same time as altitude
and it was just my body was fighting
this battle against itself.
So we got back to camp.
I think I just kinda sat in a chair for
awhile and said a lot of weird stuff.
I think I said like a
when I think I said,
um,
what's the name of this mountain?
Because that's you got to know the name
of what's going to kill you or something
weird like don't this mountains out to
get us.
Joe,
were you thinking about your family?
Yeah.
Hell yeah.
Right.
That's the first thing you think about
what?
Sharing the bad situation in the woods.
Why did I come here?
Why do I have to be this adventuring
asshole and that,
yes,
that 100 percent.
I think I was more focused on levity and
more focused on like making jokes and
making it seem okay,
right?
Because that's the only way that my mind
can wrap ourselves around.
Like,
oh,
hey,
you dumb ass.
You trained for a month.
He went to Nepal,
what do you do?
And you're an idiot.
You get a kid,
you'll live in Texas.
You.
This is what the fuck.
What the fuck are you do?
And this is your brain and body.
Are you
telling you dummy,
don't do this.
Right?
But at the same time I'm like,
I'm here.
It's amazing.
These people,
this place,
the feeling,
the spirit,
like you know,
you got to get through it.
Like if there was anything to get
through then you,
it would be this like and so you get.
I got hardened to that fact and I think
eventually I had some water and I went
to sleep and I woke up in the middle of
the night and Ben,
the magic was in the 10th question is a
little medical bag and sleeping in there
with me.
So it was,
I feel like that serious.
I think they had a discussion while I
was sleeping about do we just.
Does he wake up in a helicopter?
You know,
does he wake up going back to Kathmandu,
which is probably the right conversation
to have.
It's a Bob Seger song.
Wake it
up and Katmandu.
That's right.
A baby and a wolf.
Did you tell anybody about the baby or
the baby?
Eventually.
Eventually,
right at the moment.
Then the baby was there.
I'm like,
listen baby.
Wow.
Let's make.
Let's make a pact.
I'm going to keep you under wraps for
awhile.
So you're basically like tripping balls.
Yeah I don't know the science of it.
Somebody smarter than me can tell you
like what actually was going on,
whether I was just a pussy or there was
some actual scientific stuff going down.
Parker joint since it's illegal,
it's legal here in California.
It's just hit me hard.
Keep going.
I'll keep going while you're doing that.
Um,
so the next day there's more to the
story to tell.
There's probably so much detail but the
next day we get up and I'm feeling okay.
Feeling pretty weak.
Like Ah,
this is still not,
not poisoning week.
Yeah.
Like that weird thing where you feel
like you can't really make a fist like
achy kinda.
So we did a little bit of filming in the
morning and it was like,
hey o'brian,
can you make it up for this acclamation
hike?
Right.
Can you go up this hill right here?
Good.
Uh,
can you make it up this hill right here?
If you can,
we'll let you keep going kind of deal.
So they give you a test.
I could test you on Brad.
And so I get up there.
I'd go with one of the guides.
Roger,
let me get up.
We started hiking.
We get up over this rise.
I'm feeling pretty good shit.
Okay.
That was a bad moment in time.
I'm going,
but we're back.
Sheep.
Come on when sheep.
Let's do it.
And we're going.
I think we probably had five or six hour
hike into the next camp.
We started getting into sheep country at
that time and um,
we're,
we're hiking and I'm feeling pretty good
and we get to a spot where our main
guide mon had spotted some sheep and so
we get to where he had spotted some
sheep and I'm feeling tired.
I'm like,
we're going up as we go,
so we may be there 14,000
feet or 13,
five at that point.
And um,
we sit down and he's glass and the
sheet,
but I remember glass and I'm like,
oh,
okay.
And they were like so far up,
you can't imagine going that far to get
him.
And then I,
my stomach just like,
oh no.
Oh God,
my stomach is completely screwed.
But start going.
You get that muscle but muscle or your
butt,
like when you're holding a weight that
you're going to drop.
Yeah,
that's what I was good.
Jesus,
let me say this about shitting your
pants.
Everybody on this,
on this
trip was okay with it because it was
happening.
It was shitting their pants was like,
it's not like
you're on a plane and it was like our
camera guy.
One of our main camera guys are non.
Who was an amazing person.
The whole nother podcast about that guy.
He shit his pants I think during like
day one and I don't know how many pairs
of pants he had,
but I remember watching him like
scrubbing the shit out of his pants,
thinking shit that's going to get
interesting,
but by the time we got into sheep
country we were all okay with the
occasional short or whatever's going on.
I think it's fine
because your body's just like you're
realizing that your mind has a
directive.
That's right,
but your body is dealing with some
pretty extreme conditions
and I wonder.
I always wonder now looking back on it
or like how well I would have done if
there wasn't sickness and like I had
some stuff like go to Katmandu and it's
just dust and dirt and all this
craziness and I had going into it like
respiratory issues and then sickness and
then visions of things and so by the
time you get in there,
you know,
it really makes you respect the fuck out
of Jim shockey.
Oh yeah.
For people who don't know who jim
shockey is,
Jim shockey is extremely respected in
the hunting world.
The,
let's just step aside with that.
He's an amazing accomplished hunter,
but maybe even more important than that.
He's got a show called uncharted and his
uncharted show is so good.
It's so good that it really shouldn't be
considered a hunting show because what
it really is,
is him exploring cultures in the most
remote parts of the world.
Jim goes to these strange villages in
the middle of Russia that no one goes
to Ivan.
I got all kinds of stories.
Like last time I was at Jim's place up
in Canada.
I'm like,
I said,
he's,
what are you doing this weekend?
I'm like,
I fly home,
hang out with the family.
What are you doing?
He's like,
ah,
Bison and Poland,
they have bison and that's what I think
is what he said.
I can be,
I can be the same kind of thing.
Right.
And,
and uh,
when I was,
I saw Jim about a month before we left
for Nepal and Jim had been at,
you should,
if you can find foot,
the full episode of Jim's Nepal Hunt
with his crew.
It is,
it.
They filmed it there,
like doing cell filming.
That's kind of how I felt.
Just like you're just a,
you're just a mess.
Just a mess.
And I said to him as like going into
Paul,
Jim and like a month,
and he goes,
what?
Like,
I was like,
well,
what can I expect?
He's like,
it sucks.
It sucks.
And when somebody like Jim shockey who's
traveled the world,
literally the world,
it says,
it's going to be terrible for you little
fellow.
I was like,
oh no,
this is real.
Now I'm going to be in trouble.
Yeah.
Jim shockey has a a video or a,
an episode of his show where he went to,
I think it was Mozambique where they're
hunting crocodiles,
crocodiles,
eat all the people that work that live
and work in this village.
Yeah.
It is so crazy.
These poor.
These people live under the threat of
monsters on a daily basis,
like half the people in the village are
either missing arms or they have a chunk
taken out of their leg and one they were
there.
They lost a woman.
She was going down there either to fetch
water to wash her clothes,
and she got taken out and these people
were screaming and weeping.
It was so hard to watch man,
to watch a bunch of people wailing,
just wailing because they knew this
woman that they loved got taken under.
By the end of that,
the end of it where they cut the croc
open and pulled a.
What was it,
like a shoe or something out of the
cracks belly shirt or something like
that.
I remember we were talking about that
later on and that should be on a
different channel.
It's so good.
It's so it should be on discovery.
What's his son's name that films it?
Brantlyn brand.
Linda's a motherfucker.
He is a bad motherfucker family.
Either their daughter,
but you know,
here's my criticism of outdoor in air
quotes TV.
There's episodes like Rainelda's that
are just brilliant.
I mean Rinella show or shows rather like
Rainelda's Rinella show is just a
brilliant show.
I mean,
it easily could be on any other network.
It's.
It's shot by zero point zero.
The same people that shoot Anthony
Bourdain's show the same people that
shoot a ton of award winning Emmy Award
winning shows.
It's a brilliant show and then you got
these things that look like they shoot
them with trail cams,
a bunch of dip shits.
They're all,
you know,
they're,
the Lord blessed me when this bull came
over the ridge,
you know,
like,
okay,
if they just think there's a.
I'm a rampant anti-intellectualism,
like an embraced sort of like a fake
simplicity to it.
Yeah.
There's like heartland pandering that
goes on all the pandering,
pandering,
skidway look,
but then you've got Jim shockey who has
this legitimate appreciation for these
cultures that he visits all over the
world.
I mean he goes to these incredibly
remote places and communicates with
these tribes,
people that live in the jungle or the
mountains or wherever it is and you
could tell that this is a guy jim is
like,
what does he buy?
Probably 60 or so that he's getting up
there and he,
he realizes that he's lived a long life,
has experienced a lot of wild and
amazing things and now at this point in
life what he really desires or extreme
experiences of a humankind and also have
a wildcard in nature and was like a
different level to him.
I outdoor TV,
they is funny just because like I do
appreciate and have friends that are
like fall into that,
you know,
bubble zone buzzbuzzhome.
Yeah.
And I,
and I appreciate what they do and like
it's not for me.
I don't watch it and I'm a fan of it,
but I appreciate it.
Other bubbles like it and it's a thing,
it's,
it's hunting,
right.
But I will agree with you.
He's
on another level.
There's just a different level you could
watch Rinella is cuzdey or episode where
he just kind of like,
the whole theme is like sitting in
silence and like if you're looking for
the right,
talking about his dad talking about
growing up and there's no music.
It's this brilliant episode.
It's wonderful.
And so you could watch something like
that and then every once in a while
you'll see one where you're like,
what's going on?
It's like there's such a juxtaposition
between what Steve and Jim and some of
these other Hartland bowhunter these
guys were able to like even
cinematically produce.
Yeah.
Heartland bowhunter,
they do a really good job with their
editing and footage and they do
really good job in remy,
like solo hunters are really great
timber timber net.
Um,
and so like there is this really good
and like,
I don't know if they're pulling up the
ones that aren't so good or they're
being brought down.
I'm not sure.
I think it's either or,
you know,
like,
you know what?
Another one of my favorite is western
hunter.
Yeah,
that's an amazing show.
You know,
and nate,
Nate Simmons is fucking so good on that.
And,
and I will say as a hunter,
it's hard.
Like if you really all you care about
hunting,
just want to read,
read,
read.
There's a lot of bad information.
There's a lot on television in
television and
got like western hunter,
which is a lot of really good
information.
It's public land and what he does is go
deep into the back country hiking sets
up camp and does it the hard way.
That's the real hard way.
There's a lot of the man.
It's hard to tell people that to tune
into a show if they've never had any
appreciation whatsoever for hunting.
It'd be hard.
Yeah.
What showed you tuned into,
you know,
I don't.
I mean it would be there in my,
there's three.
I feel like western hunter,
there's a few like into the back country
is really good too,
but meat eaters,
probably the one that would send them
to.
I'd be like,
narration that you're going to get and
the intellectual understanding of like
how to present these subjects and how to
I.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
That's what's important to me.
Like as I get along in my life and
career and like I have a son now and
I've trying to figure out what I want
him to know.
Like it's important to me that there's
good.
There's people like Steven now out there
representing kind of my thoughts and
feelings in a way that I probably
couldn't,
you know.
Um,
so I don't want to try.
I don't want to struggle with that.
I don't want to like if he says,
Hey dad,
let's watch them outdoor channel.
I don't want to be like,
oh I dunno man.
Like,
so I,
I,
I do appreciate Steve for what he does.
And there's a,
there's a bunch of them that are really
good.
And I guess I would say at the end of
the day I've always struggled with being
in a room full of hunters and watching
the outdoor channel because we're
hypercritical of every little thing.
Like why did he draw,
why not draw?
Well there's that,
but that's,
that's different to me.
I think that flows into the actual,
like the quality of the content and how
you know it because
I feel like if I'm watching Nate Simmons
or Steve Rinell or Ramey warrant and
those guys I don't think should be
second guessing
what those guys do in the field because
you're,
you have a level of proficiency.
To me that's like the layman watching
UFC fight and go,
why didn't conor punch him there?
And I'm like listen,
it's fucking crazy.
You don't think he knows when to punch
and when not to punch.
Like this is a stupid way of looking at
it.
So if you would compare the UFC to
hunting television,
there is no meter for how you get on
hunting television.
You have money and you buy air time,
you're there,
you know,
there's just no,
there's no qualified.
We'll explain that because most people
have no idea.
So on the outdoor channel and sports.
So I can you,
if you want to put a show on comedy
central,
you have to make a deal with comedy.
Central is good for real producers,
for real writers.
You have to pack a jet.
They're going to invest in it.
It's a big deal to get to launch it
right after tosh point.
Oh,
on whatever.
They're going to be invested in it too.
If is good.
We do good.
Everybody combined and the cable
channels that are outdoors.
Sportsmans channel is the business model
is not that.
If you.
You pay the network for the air time.
Essentially you deliver them content.
They have very little oversight over
what you delivered them.
There's rules.
You know how many times you can show a
kill shot.
There's like there's.
There's what?
They have rules.
Yeah.
Rules what?
Yeah,
hold on.
They have rules on how many times you
can show a kill shot fairly sure because
you can't like shoot a deer two minutes
into the episode and just dash is washed
close up with a deer's eyes.
The Arrow goes a close up on the Arrow
is a good thing.
We brought that red cameras all death
metal and dying feet up in the air,
kicking chicken or the egg.
There can be a show like that of Nutty
fucking chose those of you that are like
kind of metal inspired fear no evil,
but.
So there are God right there are like,
I'm trying to be diplomatic and rugged
there.
There are um,
some really good shows but,
but you pay and there's some shows that
are owned by the network,
but that is the,
the minority,
the majority of shows are people who are
paying for air time and then companies
come in and sponsor their show and pay
that for that for now.
Weird though that a network on actual
regular direct TV,
like you can get to a channel six.
Oh,
five,
six.
Oh,
six,
six.
Oh four.
That's the,
you know,
what's interesting,
the hunting channels which are like,
I would say overwhelmingly Christian,
like in terms of viewership and in terms
of the people that are on the show are
literally two or three channels away
from black dicks and white chicks on
direct TV.
The channels important channels are like
five 96,
five 97,
and then he goes six,
oh,
four.
Y'all are out here representing God's
great earth and the beauty and the
bounty of Jesus Christ out here in the
like know you're always two clicks away
from the terrible black poles and white
holes.
Next on direct TV,
click,
click.
Jesus has blessed me with this Turkey,
longer guyer and a freaking Hyena
massacre.
Electro is two clicks away.
That's the Internet.
This is television like you know,
it's.
Those lines are blurred.
They're going to get super blurred.
They're more blurred now than ever
before.
Steven Cole Bear said that the president
of the fucking United States uses
poutines Dick like he uses his mouth.
Has Putin's cock holster?
Yes.
Stephen Colbert is very religious,
right?
He is.
He said that when you sat it on
television recently.
Yeah,
he's on the show.
Yeah.
His idea was he was going to.
This is the inside story.
He was baiting trump to respond to him
and finally after he said that trump did
respond,
call them second rate and not funny.
All these things,
ratings,
dying,
bad,
all this stuff,
and then Cole bear gets on TV and he
goes,
Mr Trump,
out of all the things that I know you
don't understand,
the one thing I thought you did
understand was show business.
You responded to me.
That means I win and trolled the
president.
He told the president fact that the
president is [inaudible] is an issue.
He's trolling as well as being trolled
the bowl.
Joe Scarborough and his fiance.
Do you know that whole story where the
president,
a woman came to Maro Lago,
but she had facelift surgery and she was
bleeding very badly and he did not go.
Did Not hang out with them.
He tweeted that,
am I missing last week?
I got to get back on twitter.
It's so bad that scarborough left the
Republican Party.
What is happening in the world was like,
look,
if you guys are going to support this,
he goes,
I'm not a republican anymore.
He goes,
I'm going.
Independent goes,
I still have republican values.
I felt still belonged to the gl,
but I'm not going to do this.
We live.
We live in strange test,
strangest the strangest times.
Joe Rogan.
That's why my tour is called strange
times.
Go to Joe Rogan Dot net forward slash
20.
Can you tell this weekend will be there.
You're going to be there.
I'll be there.
Yeah,
we're going to be there for.
It's total coincidence.
My wife doesn't believe it,
but the total total archery challenge is
actually there at the same tile.
Hunting is total coincidence.
Total coincidence.
I can't believe this baby.
Absolutely.
I'm doing a show in the wilds of New
Mexico in September.
I always wanted to visit this native
American reservation.
It turns out that they invited me to
hunt bison there.
I mean,
I don't want to go,
but.
But I don't want to 75 people coming to
the show.
I don't want to be disrespectful.
Well,
strange times it is.
I don't.
I must not like I do.
Every once in a while I'll flick on a
CNN,
CNN or something,
but I don't.
I'm not one of those people.
I've seen people in my life that gets so
wrapped up in that stuff that it
becomes.
It becomes their reality.
I've never been affected by anything
Donald Trump has done in my daily life.
The healthcare thing is a different
deal,
but.
But I think in my daily life there's few
things that directly affect me other
than something that seems existential
other than the environment and freaking
healthcare.
Right,
but that doesn't even affect you or you
feel it.
You ignore it.
That's part of the problem is that we
don't like on a day to day basis.
It doesn't touch your skin.
It doesn't make your.
Your nerve endings responds so you can
choose.
There's.
There's a choice,
right?
Man,
you could choose to not.
You can choose to create some sort of
bubble for that news and politics and
let only what's important in.
That's Kinda what I try to do.
I don't know if I'm always doing it,
but I don't just turn it on and sit
there and watch CNN,
Russia,
oh man,
I got.
If I'm.
If I see a restaurant on the street,
I'll punch him right in his face.
You saw the news report where the
reporter,
he admitted that this whole Russia thing
is kind of bullshit.
It's just for ratings and I was like,
well,
as a job,
a journalism major.
I'm like,
of course it is.
Yeah,
Of course it is.
If it bleeds,
it leads.
It's.
Yeah,
it's.
I don't know what's real anymore.
No,
I really don't.
I don't want to ever say.
I mean I want to look into things for
sure that it's not that I'm not,
I'm not thinking about it,
but man,
I watch house of cards too much drinking
there.
Joe Rogan.
This is a not a sponsor because wasn't
important.
It's Zv.
Do you know what I would like to know?
It's a Stevia flavored soft drinks and
yeah,
it's 100 percent.
No sugar.
This one is their energy drink.
I think it has 120 milligrams of
caffeine,
which is like a good cup of coffee.
Not starbucks,
Venti I think as 200.
So it's not quite,
but a,
not quite a starbucks.
Venti not even a grand day,
but it has zero sugar and it actually
tastes really good.
Would you like one?
I would,
yeah.
Oh,
you want me to shut down this
motherfucker Xavia?
Yeah.
Sorry,
that was really good.
Soft drinks to do we have any soft
drinks in the fridge or just the energy
drink?
Throw some of those soft drinks in the
fridge for the next as a first time
visiting California.
I got to do shit like,
like drink this.
Cvs.
Yeah.
People in California don't respect if
you haven't been here.
They're like,
oh,
you don't even know what to do.
Yeah,
I've been to your many great airports
but never.
Like this morning I went out and got
like a parfait with granola.
Yeah,
there was some granola in there and then
I got A.
I went to the pool a little bit and did
some emails.
Nice and drank a sparkling water.
Did you see any hose?
There were.
No.
They were in travel.
If you're going to travel next time you
got to land in Beverly Hills or at least
go to a hotel in beverly hills.
We have the rest of today like we can.
Yeah.
I really need to see like the comedy.
I poke my head in there.
They go there tonight though,
unfortunately.
Yeah,
we would have been those cold or no
grape soda.
So it is grape soda,
but it's zero sugar.
Try One of those.
It's good.
They're delicious.
And by the way,
not a sponsor.
I was going to say,
man,
I get in trouble all the time for shit
but not in trouble,
but people accused me,
send me emails,
bitches.
They always think that for whatever
reason I'm getting paid for stuff.
I get people got mad at me about,
uh,
that Yeti thing that I did,
which by the way,
my friend Ben Works for Yeti.
I'm going to be honest here.
This is a Yeti rambler and will send me
some Yeti things,
but I bought Yeti shit before he even
worked for Yeti and I was telling all
amazing Yeti and you made that very
clear to me too.
I was like,
ah man,
I worked for Yeti.
Now you know,
do you need a cooler or something like
that.
Yeah.
These bro.
I already had two yetis back off.
Brian already got Yeti's.
They're the best.
It's there if you've never had one and
people go loose spoons with.
You're right,
you're right.
You don't have to have one,
but I'm telling you if you have the
money and you want a crazy fucking
cooler,
they are the shit.
This is very good.
What do you feel about the ones that.
There's one that,
um,
that,
that totally copied Yeti like in every
way.
But I mean,
they copied the way.
It's very flattering the way the logo
is.
And someone was saying,
hey man,
this one is like half the price and it
does just as good.
I'm like,
okay.
And then there was like this battle
after I posted that in the comment
section of instagram where people like
their copycats.
It's no,
that's,
there is debates.
I mean it's a good robust debate on
what's the better cooler.
It's funny that Yeti has kind of,
well yeah,
I created the premium cooler category
and then,
and,
and when you create a category like that
when you and become a business,
yet he is,
you're going to have people that follow
along and they kind of need us and we
kinda need them unless whatever.
But as long as there's not,
they're not infringing on the things
that are our intellectual property,
things of that nature.
As far as that goes.
I know as a company man,
we look forward like we have stuff we're
coming out with now.
Things we're doing.
We're not worried about people that are,
that are copying.
This is.
I'll just continue to follow along.
Look coolers,
coolers.
It's all good.
But what I.
I mean I,
when I find something that I like,
that's good.
I like to tell people about it and for
whatever reason people always assess why
is that such a hard thing to get their
heads around?
Well,
because it's,
they're cynical and they should be
because people are full of shit.
There's a lot of people that are full of
shit.
But I swear to fucking God,
if there's ever a time where I have an
ad for like the ads for my podcast,
everybody knows their ads.
People pay for those ads.
When we were talking about it,
that was my argument.
I'm like,
people pay for ads and Joe reads the ad.
He never,
he never just like frozen during a
pocket pockets,
like,
ah,
let me just pull out.
This doesn't happen.
And that's like Stevia.
I have zero.
I bought this,
I ran out.
I ordered these all on Amazon.com
forum.
It's very delicious.
Yeah,
they're fucking great.
I drink this shit all the time.
You know why?
Because it tastes good and it doesn't
have any bullshit in it.
Like this is all just zero calories and
zero sugar,
you know?
I mean it's grape soda,
but it's clear because they don't have
any per se.
It's great.
But look clear.
It looks like fire and water.
It's like the Zima.
Right?
That's great.
He still loves him.
It's not as easy add.
I don't have any fucking nothing to do
with that company.
They're not a sponsor,
but isn't that the whole world?
Like facts are,
you know,
people will assign their motives to
facts and like everything.
Right.
I could say I work for you.
Yeah,
I could say he's a great cooler.
It's the best I've ever used.
I use them all the time more than any
normal person because my job and I found
it to be.
I'm proud to work for the company
because it's something I can stand
behind.
I still have people to be like,
ah,
whatever man.
Right.
You're just shilling for your company,
Bro.
But it's.
Isn't it smart though that people are
that cynical?
I mean,
look,
but here's a perfect example.
I rant and rave about the glory of a
1965 corvette.
I don't work for 1965 corvettes.
Okay.
Well it's just like there's a reality
about certain things that are awesome
that people have created that I
celebrate and I don't.
I don't say I'm not going to talk about
z via because they're not a sponsor.
I'm not going to talk about Yeti because
they're not a sponsor.
It's interesting to me.
It's all interesting.
I like,
I like when people get it right.
You have this like this podcast where
you've done your closing on a thousand
episodes and if you remove like all
consumer products from the conversation,
it would suck.
The problem is people boiled down
innovation to a consumer product.
They boil it down to a material
possession that somebody has to
purchase.
Right.
I'm not looking at it that way.
I'm being honest when I'm.
When I'm looking at something that
someone had someone create some new
innovation,
I'm looking at like,
oh look what they did.
Oh yeah.
I wish.
I wish I could have figured that out.
Like what is it?
I don't even think that because I'm not
an inventor,
but I do.
I do get excited about only archery side
of things.
Bluetooth.
Is that really,
that link I sent you?
That is real.
It's real.
What's it called?
What's the name of the company?
The bread crumb tech.
Bluetooth knocks.
The problem is I'm shooting 86 pounds,
so I'm here to have a strong man's
listen.
There's not going to be any knocks
poking out.
We can track those things.
A lot of people tell you know through me
to tell you,
just to just dial it down a little bit
too.
A little bit.
For Real.
Yeah,
for real.
I've had a couple people say,
you can't be promoted shooting that much
poundage.
I just want you motherfuckers check out
the show might go this way.
I don't understand why people don't.
It doesn't factor into their mind that
some people are stronger than them.
It's true.
Like if you pull 60 pounds,
I don't feel bad.
I'm not upset at you.
Look at these things.
Look.
So they shoot this Arrow and then with
your phone you can track the knock
through a bluetooth device that has some
sort of a gps locator on it.
Oh,
you shoot it in the grass,
which I do often.
He missed it.
That's my best brand.
Bates.
Brandon Bates from a or mef rocky
mountain elk foundation.
Good man.
Let's get into America.
Had on America.
I got to America.
Case for my phone.
America,
America.
Nothing better than wait till we have
the new studio and the America flag in
the background.
The flag we got sitting back there.
Jamie.
God Damn Gory.
Have you previewed the new student?
The new CEO,
but he knows anything.
Oh,
okay.
There's not a new studio when it.
When it comes,
it will be epic.
You guys don't worry about it,
but these knocks,
it's going to be a good way to find
arrows for sure,
but what's what's interesting is it'll
be a good way to track animals.
If you shoot an animal,
like a lot of times people will shoot an
animal and the animal runs and it's in
thick cover and you can't find it.
It's dead.
It died quick.
Like an animal can run 200 yards inside
of a few seconds and die immediately and
you might never find it,
so if you shoot exactly where,
even though you put a hole on each of
his lungs.
Yeah,
the two inch dynamic diameter range
brought out or one and a quarter or
whatever.
Whatever it is,
it can run 100 yards.
Examples that place we were at a Texas.
Oh yeah.
This place had these scrub oaks that
were six feet tall and you could not get
into and the animals you would shoot
one.
The guys were talking to us about pigs,
like,
yeah,
we had a pig contest and shot three last
two.
What was wrong with you?
And it didn't make sense until you go
there you go,
oh yeah,
hey,
are you going to find that lead there?
How would we go there?
Like why would we do that?
Well,
we just need to trim that stuff.
Yeah,
it's just.
Should've talked to them about that.
I don't.
I think they kind of knew where they
were putting it off,
but it was just like trees as Christ.
You have so much Bush.
Well there's any place that you hunt,
like especially when you think about
recovering game even though will not.
You think it's fairly flat place.
Like if I shoot a deer,
I'll see it go down or whatever.
It goes behind a bush or it goes over a
rise and you go and you're like,
oh crap.
Well how about the place that we were at
the last day where the grass was six
feet high and the animals were in the
grass when they were waiting.
What's crazy was ben and I were there.
I shot at this one,
deer and other deer that were like 30
feet away from us,
jumped out of the bushes like they were
hiding.
They,
they heard us talking,
they knew we were there and they just
laid low.
Yeah,
well they like,
they laid low and then you shot an arrow
and they were like,
I know what that sounds like.
Yeah.
And they ran off and I,
we knew they didn't cross into the next
little paddock,
like the next across this road.
So I circled around and got up on this
mound so I could see into the grass and
I could see it in there.
They're just like talking to her like,
Shit,
what do we do?
Joe Rogan's.
I was trying
to get you to go in there,
but you were what,
like six feet away from these things by
the time,
by the time we got to him I was no,
no further.
Within 15 feet.
Yeah.
Jargon an to here that has sort of grown
out of his head.
Multiple pretty crazy,
but they're just.
Animals evolved to experience whatever
the dangers of their environment are.
There dangers are 100 percent people.
Yeah.
That animals probably four or five years
old had been around people for four or
five years.
I was like,
oh,
I get it when people are around,
they're trying to eat you,
man.
People have never gotten me in this
grass.
Yeah.
Nobody else has ever been able to do it.
So how did you,
how did the Nepal thing and you get it
together,
get it together?
I think we left off at.
I started to get sick while the whole
next day I was puking shit and,
and just,
I had the flu.
Everybody else got.
But I just got it like two days later.
And so it was that day.
The first day we'd seen sheep,
so we were three,
I think four days into the end of the
track and we were camping somewhere at
14,000
feet.
And um,
the next day the guy was with another
guy that had a tag.
Coal goes up,
shoots a sheep and like six,
like they climb up to thousand feet,
60 mile an hour,
wind bursts,
microbursts,
frostbite conditions like these guys
when they came back,
looked beaten.
And these are cold Kramer,
who we went with is a Kodiak Alaska bear
guide and a mountain hunter.
And His hardcores gets.
And uh,
I looked at his face when he got back
and I had just been in my 10 old day
puking and trying to stay alive and I
looked at his face and he's like,
oh my God.
And I thought I can't make it over there
to the latrine,
let alone up this mountain to kill a
sheep.
Um,
and so I kinda had resigned myself to
like,
this is it,
man,
I can't,
I wish I was healthy enough to do it,
but that's,
I don't want to get up there and then
have issues and not be able to get
helicopter rescue.
And so we,
we talked about it but the worst part,
and I'll just have to tell us just
because it's like the low point of my
trip there.
The third night in the,
when we got to camp,
I was puking in the vestibule of my tent
and all the,
all the,
the Nepali guys or are you okay?
You okay?
Okay.
No,
not okay.
I'm puking and then fell asleep.
Woke back up.
I had to go to the bathroom.
Then the medic is there.
He's helping me to the bathroom,
like I can't,
I'm not gonna make it,
I can't stand up,
so I literally just Kinda like huddled
over in the snow and pull my pants down
and just write it in the middle of camp.
Just let it go
and
I just remember do it.
Like just thinking,
oh my God.
And I look up and there's all these
porters,
Sherpas with their headlamps on.
Okay,
that's that bad.
You okay?
I'm like,
look at me.
I'm dying.
And
so that was the lowest point of the trip
and that I think the next day cold
killed a sheep.
The day after that I went up the
mountain with a both in mid day just for
another,
like acclimation.
Could I make it?
We got into a group of sheep,
didn't make it happen,
but I went up the mountain basically
probably 1200 feet,
just a good climb.
Went back down there like,
okay,
tomorrow is kind of the last chance
because we're almost out of areas to
hunt these sheep.
And we went up the valley,
I want to say like eight miles.
I got,
I got it written down somewhere,
88 miles and being on death's door to
his store and I wasn't to be the 100
percent on it.
I wasn't carrying a pack or anything.
I just had trekking poles and a bio
harness and I was just like one foot,
one foot and we got into these mountain
passes in these valleys where there was
like two,
three feet of snow and it was frozen on
the top and you were just like every
step you would crunch two feet down,
like boom,
boom.
And it was an hour of that and there was
a time during that where we,
we summited this,
the probably the highest peak we were
at,
which is mid 15,
close to 16 and I was just like,
I can't this.
I hope the sheep are right there because
this is it like this as far as I can go.
And we rested and we glassy sheep and
there they are like a mile and a half
away.
Found this other giant ravine and up on
this other flat.
And I remember even the guys who were
with looking at like,
he's not gonna be able to go over there
and I just,
I just remember thinking like,
this is what I'm doing it like I'm just
going to go.
And we slid on our butts,
like down the side of this mountain.
Me and two guides slid on our butts down
the side of the snowy.
Icy Bank.
Got Up,
walked a half a mile,
popped up over this ridge there.
The sheep are within 300 yards.
In about 20 minutes.
I got,
got on a big Ram and shot him.
Wow.
And uh,
yeah.
And there was no celebration.
There was no,
I wasn't even happy,
I don't think because you're so out of
it.
Yeah.
I think I just kinda like slumped over
on my pack.
I was laying prone is like slumped over
my pack and like.
Okay.
Did you eat it that night?
Yeah,
they ate.
The whole thing was not all that night.
But Julian.
Oh yeah.
I was too sick.
Like the spices that curry spices,
even the smell of that curry spice.
I couldn't even take like eight.
A good bit of it.
But they carried up your shit on
everything.
But even the tent smelled like that.
So I like the cook tent.
I couldn't even really be in there.
It was.
I end up just eating rice for a couple
days.
I just couldn't walk.
Couldn't stomach because it just such a
gnarly experience.
So everybody ate your sheep,
like you didn't even bring it back?
No,
you can't bring the meat back here.
Anyways.
So the point was,
so they had,
they had mostly already eaten cold sheep
within a day and a half or two days.
And I'm talking 20 people,
Twenty four,
25 of.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
That burden and through the burning.
And not only did they eat the eyeballs,
we so call a shot a sheep and he was
keeping out the head,
take the off head,
pop the eyeballs out.
And I think jokingly handed to one of
the porters like,
ha,
eat this.
And I haven't watched that dude put it
on the stick and put it over a fire and
eat it.
Yeah,
well I wouldn't.
I mean that's meat.
So they didn't see this personally,
but they were picky.
Yeah.
They took the punch to the gut sack and
cut it open,
flat out the insights and took it back
and cook that too.
You know,
it's Kinda like a Pegasus try kind of
thing.
And so I mean they just like,
they just devoured the thing.
Would you go back?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm going to northwest territories.
That's going to suck a then we'll be bad
though.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
I think about like,
I often think about like what if I'm
glad it happened the way it did because
I get,
I got so much perspective on the way
back because we still had two days to
hike out,
to get back to Tia,
picked up to go to go back to Katmandu.
It was two and a half,
three days,
hike out and hike out.
The first day we were hiking out after I
shot my sheep and I had a night's rest.
And I remember getting back in like
midnight,
I don't know,
we,
we got back at like 10:00
PM had left at six in the morning from
killing my sheet and I was just so like
emotionally,
spiritually just fucked.
And I remember thinking well tomorrow
they're going to give us a rest day.
And then the guide was like,
nope.
No,
like it's too hot,
it's too late.
We're all getting sunburn.
And I had like blisters on the roof of
my mouth from the sun.
My whole.
My whole roof of your mouth.
Yeah.
From like going up and the sun bouncing
off the snow.
Hit your mouth.
What's blisters?
Sunburn on the roof of your mouth.
Did.
That's insane.
Even heard of that before.
I feel like that's a pretty common thing
for guys that go that elevations,
hikers and stuff.
Wow.
It might not be.
So do you have like sunscreen on your
lips and your face and I'll you through.
I did,
but like I didn't really think about
that because I was hot but I wasn't the
field burning up.
But like there's photos I look at now
and I'm like,
my lips are cracking open and bleed and
I got like it was.
Yeah.
And if you watch shockey's episode when
he was in Nepal,
it's similar like they're self filming
and it's like this pretty visceral.
They get something out of that though
other than the survival.
So much out of that I got like,
I've,
I've written this now,
I probably wrote like 20,000
words on the trip,
but I got this like amazing feeling
first being around people that are,
that,
not primitives the wrong word,
but that removed from society.
They don't have,
they don't really even have the option
to be modern.
Like they don't have,
they couldn't get it.
They couldn't get a chainsaw if they
wanted to.
Like they have an ax and they need to
chop wood and like just being around
that level of just primitive people and
that they're primitive.
The wrong word,
I'll think of something better than
that.
But their spirit was so infectious.
Like they're happy people.
And you have these Sherpas,
importers,
who,
you know,
those big sick bags,
the big roller top bags.
We took one to base camp because they
told us,
oh we can leave it,
we won't take it in the hunt.
These guys would take like a 90 pound
suitcase,
put it on top of their head.
Just go walking up these trails I was
describing like it was nothing to put on
their head.
Yeah.
They balanced everything in a basket on
her head and all these porters a 90
pound bag.
And they would do more than that.
Two hundred pounds.
What?
Yeah.
Head strap basket back here.
Two hundred pounds.
Yeah.
If not more than that.
What kind of disc issues?
Those guys,
they don't care.
I mean,
and they're wearing like these guys are
wearing like sandals and some of them
were born in like old sneakers and
they're just wearing whatever clothes
that they would able to gather and
they're doing these amazing things and
when they take a break from something
that you or I could never conceive of
doing,
they're like happy as could be there.
Their perspective on life is only
hardship.
And poverty,
that's all they know,
but that's the only thing they'll ever
know,
but yet they're happier than,
than I think maybe I could ever be.
Does a big part of,
uh,
Sebastian younger's book tribe.
A big part of it is like how living easy
and not,
not sustaining massive amounts of
difficulty like most people do in these
impoverished communities is one of the
reasons why people aren't happy is that
people actually need struggle,
which is very counterintuitive for
people.
It is.
And I remember coming back,
there was a bunch of moments that I
could describe all these moments where I
just like,
I'd be at my wit's end just thinking I'm
just a regular Dominican,
like some adventure.
What am I doing?
And I'd get to a point where obviously
pleased and I would look over and here
become this porter,
this 25 year old kid with a basket
strapped on his head with,
you know,
100 pounds of stuff wearing sneakers.
And I got $400 Italian boots on and
sixth gear.
And I'm like.
And it would always come with these
opportune moments where I'd look over
and I'd see that and pick,
oh crap,
like this person is here I am.
Yeah,
I am in physical pain and things are
happening,
but like to have the mental fortitude
that those people have and they don't
know they have it.
That's just how they're wired.
And so I came back after the whole thing
and I remember hiking out being like in
the front of the group,
all of a sudden like really feeling
good.
My packs back on my back.
I'm like energized again,
thinking like this best feeling in the
world,
that feeling of overcoming that thing
and being on the downhill slope.
I'd get back just for that feeling if I
could catch it again.
I think a big part of the thing of that
is just you don't really appreciate what
it feels like to be healthy until you're
not healthy.
Uh,
I don't advise anybody to get food sick,
food sickness or food poisoning.
But one of the things about it as man,
once it's over,
you realize you go,
God,
like being healthy is so critical.
It's like everything,
it doesn't matter
your status,
your money,
the,
your friends did that.
None of that means shit if you're
unhealthy.
Yeah,
I mean,
and it's the people in Nepal live in
this.
They just went through a civil war in
the recent decades and these people were
like at the epicenter of it and there,
you know,
our trip gave them jobs.
It gave them purpose,
gave like there's a lot of things.
Our main guide mon door didn't have
shoes until he was 13 and they used to
go hunting and they would build their
own guns and he described to us about a
couple of times where like,
he had never hiking and hunting sheep
and the gun would blow up on his back
and blow a shirt off.
Stuff like that.
They were like making,
oh my god,
muzzle loaders and using matchsticks as,
as a powder.
I feel like wow.
So there was all these stories like
that,
that um,
perspective perspective and like you
can't let people say,
oh,
your trophy hunted that sheet maybe.
But there was so much more to it that if
anybody would ever want to see that just
ate it.
We ate it.
Yeah,
I mean,
what does that mean?
What it means is people make a
distinction that you did not have to
bring that animal back in order for you
to survive.
That's right.
So that's the only way
motive to me then,
right.
If they call me a trophy and I would say
this,
I would say look,
you go into a war torn area of the world
where after the war they don't have a
lot of chance to make money.
Like the tourism is kind of died once
you've been through or it's really not a
happy place to be.
And plus the place we were hunting and
the.
It was the,
I think that the rope,
a 10 hunting reserve is like the only
hunting reserve in Nepal.
Like,
and it's heavily regulated.
Like there's 19 blue sheep tags a year.
So you're thinking like everybody that
goes,
how many people a year go to Mount
Everest base camp?
Thousands.
I don't know what the number is,
but it's thousands.
I think there's,
we were probably within a couple of
dozen westerners that had been to that
area postwar and had brought 24,
25 jobs plus the people that prep that
plus all that stuff,
so like seeing that it's pretty powerful
to me and shooting that sheep and not
even given a shit whether the horns made
it back or not.
I mean you,
somebody questioned my motive all they
want,
but within the system and the structure
that's set up there now hunting is one
of the more valuable things that they.
One of the more valuable tools they have
to get better at everything that their
lives that they're having.
It's their resource,
the resource.
It's.
Yeah,
and you know,
we can look down upon that,
but it is a natural resource and along
the same veins is like if you live in an
area that has fracking,
that's a natural resource.
If you live in an area that,
you know,
they dig minerals out of the ground,
that's a natural resource.
It's not a good or a bad thing.
It's just the reality of their
environment.
And so there's so many.
I think that there is arguments against
what we did.
If somebody broke it down,
like I always try to break it down for
me in the side,
I think we will say like,
why don't you just take pictures of it?
You know,
what are you doing?
You just go up there,
pay 20 grand or whatever you pay for
hunt like that.
Take some pictures.
Well,
partly the challenge people don't
understand how difficult it is to do
what you did like to do what you did and
then have this final accomplishment
which is the get close enough to an
animal where either it doesn't know
you're there or you get an a good place
where it can't win to you who doesn't
smell you and you can take it out and
kill it like it's hard to do so insanely
hard to do.
I've got all my own personal reasons
wanting to kill that sheep and I would
also say like present a better plan.
Then are you going to pay what hunters
are willing to pay and already are you
going to be a part of conservation
regulation?
The way that hunters are as a,
as a trekker and a photographer like
give me
better idea.
Okay,
but here's the problem with that.
Their,
their response to that could easily be,
you know,
what about if you decided to hunt
people,
if you paid a million dollars to go
hundred person and that,
that money fed all these tribes,
people in Mozambique,
is it okay to go out and hunt?
People know there's surely still have an
ethical and moral obligation to them to,
to animal rights activists.
Do you have an ethical,
moral obligation to let that sheep live?
Yeah,
and I'm on your side,
but I'm just saying on both sides.
Like I,
I,
I really do
do like because we only ate it there
because we didn't have a freezer full of
backstraps and because that thing didn't
occur the way it normally occurs for me
there was some complexity and have that.
Yeah.
In my mind,
crap man,
you know,
am I really ever here just to collect
the sheep and bring it home and show
people.
But you also filming.
Yeah.
We made.
Oh,
we made what will be hopefully an
awesome film and so at the end of the
day I checked myself and I said,
did you do it for the right reasons?
And,
and after I looked back the trip,
I'm like,
man,
there are 100 reasons why I did it and
they're all good and,
and it was what we did was a good impact
on the place he went on,
the animals that we hunted.
Like it's,
it's,
to me it's all good and I,
and I would love,
have argued with somebody that feels
differently about that.
Plus you got the trip balls and see a
fake baby and a fake wolf.
People pay a lot of money for.
Yeah man,
you get mushrooms are expensive and you
might not see a wolf.
You might not,
it might not see a baby on the road.
I'm sure there's still like a log sheet
or like a wolf shape log somewhere.
Some rock had to be something.
It was crazy.
We got to wrap this up,
man.
Let's do it.
I'm Ben O'bryan.
What is your,
uh,
your twitter that you don't use again?
I'm my twitter is at Benjamin Ob,
but I've never used that.
So instagram is always the better way to
end it.
It's Benny Ob,
b e n n y o b three.
Oh,
one.
How did you get three?
Oh,
one.
That's area code where I grew up,
but I didn't shout out to three.
Oh one.
Yeah,
man,
I created that handled when I didn't
know it would be a thing.
I thought that nobody would ever see
that.
Oh,
well now it's a thing.
Now it's a thing.
Let's do it.
We blew up,
but when we had that competition with
the people that you work with.
Alright folks,
we're out.
We're out for awhile.
Uh,
we'll be back next week with a one
podcast with my friend Ari Shaffir on
July 18th,
which is the release date of his new
Netflix special,
which is going to be fucking amazing.
It's a two part special childhood and
adulthood right though.
It is.
That's what he calls it.
What does he call it?
Ari Shaffir.
Look up bars.
Sphere on Netflix.
All right,
see you soon.
Bye.